ultimately it was the powers to issue
Energy company warrants of Entry that
triggered my resignation because I was
very concerned that not enough was being
done to divert people out of the
criminal justice system as a consequence
of the rising cost of living and that's
the topic about inquiry today is the
both the process for the issue of the
warrants and then what happens
thereafter with the installation of
meters um how many cases of that kind do
you think you dealt with during during
this time as a magistrate so by the very
nature of what we're going to discuss it
was more common
um uh in the early years and after the
changes that we'll come on to in 2019
much less common so
um in the early years I would have dealt
with these cases quite regularly um I
sat between sort of 15 and 20 days a
year and these cases would have come
quite regularly
um uh towards the end much less
frequently but um uh yes we'll come on
to talk about the nature then okay well
initially if we can go back to your your
first appointment when you were dealing
with a regular fairly regularly
um probably pre-2019 I think we'll find
out it's a relevant date
um can you just outline for us what was
the process that you typically have uh
with a list that involved applications
for warrants so is the committee
probably aware the the threshold for
issuing a warrant is actually really
very uh low there has to be some money
owed an amount big or small there's
there's no minimum there has to have
been a demand uh made to pay in full
within 28 days um or the option to pay a
deposit should not have been taken up um
the amount owed has to be not in dispute
um and a sort of a human rights notice
that is a notice that you are entitled
to come to a court and challenge the
warrant should have been issued
um and uh what we would do is a warrant
officer would come to court in person
um in we would put them on oath uh in
the in the in the witness box and we
would do this fairly frequently we'd be
dealing with a few warrants at a time
the meetings as far as the occupant was
concerned would be taking place in a
known location at a known date and time
and so they could contest the the
application if they wish to
um I think in six years as a magistrator
I never actually took part in a single
contested hearing what was much more
common was that uh the the occupant
would turn up at Court the warrant
officer would disappear into the lobby
there'd be some discussion and they'd
come back and then withdraw the warrant
rather than being basically rather than
go to a contested hearing
um and uh yes so we would have the
warrants in front of us uh we had a a
straightforward checklist that we would
go through
um basic details address purpose of
Warrant um the amount outstanding
whether the occupant was known and if
the occupant wasn't known
um what steps have been taken to
identify them or indeed to identify if
the property was occupied at all
vulnerabilities were their young
children present very elderly present
people with disabilities and all of
those checks are allowed for under the
law what we would then do is we would uh
based on the information given to us by
the warrant officer or information in
the warrant application itself we may
then go on and to ask questions such as
how many attempts there had been to uh
contact the the occupant the recency of
the last visit the amount owed whether
they've been offered a payment plan what
other efforts had been made to collect
the amount and the uh one of the
questions on vulnerability was whether
people whether the occupant might be
experiencing severe Financial insecurity
so as a consequence of that sometimes
the warrant officer would go back and
would have to check or we would reject
the warrant but if a warrant was granted
a physical piece of paper would be
passed down the bench I would sign some
of them as a magistrate
um or the apple or the application would
be declined the foundation legislation
is about 1954. um that act doesn't it um
and that gives it's been suggested to us
precious little discretion once in
effect the debt is proved and the vet
the statutory requirements for the
issuance of the warrant approved uh
that's really it you're absolutely so
and one of the things that I think it is
important for the committee to know
um because uh in various sort of public
defenses of this from the magistrates
Association and others people have been
saying look magistrates have to apply
the law there was no change in the law
there was a very substantial change in
how the court operated what the outcomes
were and the number of bailiffs knock on
people's stores and that I want to come
to because when we talk about a warrant
officer again for example some people
might think that's an officer of the
court or a police officer this is a
representative of the Energy company the
Energy company or the agents acting to
collect the debt forward effectively
um You referred to the to the checklist
that she used to have and we've got like
a specimen in front of us here and as
you say that sets out the name of the
company the name of the the applicant
um I think it means a recording any
respondents who did attend virtually
never
um and a number of applications opposed
but in particular there's this passage
in the checklist does this uh tally with
your recollection in relation to each
application is the information in
writing yes no if no stop don't you
shoot a warrant pretty obvious
um identification warrant car produced
yes no
if no stop ask them to to leave and come
back when they've got identification
obviously right and then
you're asked to check does the the
application clearly estate the enactment
from which it's based the address as you
say the purpose of the application and
the amount are outstanding
and uh
if any of that's missing
you you'd expect those to be fully
enumerated otherwise if they were
missing it would be a ground for not
issuing the warrant wouldn't it that's
right and and what you effectively have
although this doesn't cover the the full
extent of the the questions we would
often ask is there is a sense here that
this is a flowchart that you are going
through a process and applying some
judicial discretion whereas under the
current process there is a enormous
presumption that the warrant would be
granted yeah
and I understand that so
can you just help me about this uh
pre-2019 did you have any guidance as to
the application of the the Human Rights
Act process in other words
um the the right uh that the respondents
sort of occupies the premises would have
in relation to let's say article six
right to a fair trial uh or articulate
their right to Family Life which could
be affected by the disconnection of
their electricity or gas I'm aware that
uh there were for example judicial
College training courses uh that were
optional there were some parts of the
country that had best practice
checklists and Q and A's that went
beyond what we've discussed um today uh
I myself know was not given any
grounding in uh the human rights
legislation when processing these
warrants
um I want to be clear that I have
nothing but praise for hmcts's legal
advisors whose deer magistrates through
these processes in court and the
likelihood is that I would have been
advised as with the entire event as to
what we needed to be satisfied of uh in
that moment
tell me what then changed in 2019
um so I I think if I made Mr chairman
it's important to just as part of the
timeline to just stress that in in 2017
uh offgen published some uh statutory
consultation out outcomes in which they
said um warrants were being used too
readily there were less invasive
Alternatives
um they were concerned about failures to
identify vulnerable customers that some
vulnerable customers were going through
traumatic experiences and some companies
were applying excessively High charges I
think it's important to understand that
because in 2019 despite all of those
concerns uh the process was changed such
that the field was tilted even further
in favor of the Energy company so we
were required to take on as magistrates
and almost entirely performative and
uncritical role applying and approving
these warrant applications in bulk much
less judicial discretion in in the
current process so it's a bulk process
rather than having individual warrants
in front of us there'd be a spreadsheet
that spreadsheet would contain many more
applications in a list I now know I
didn't know at the time that some of the
courthouses are dealing with up to a
thousand per list it was my experience
that I was dealing with between 50 and
100.
um the occupants don't know when where
what time uh the application is being
dealt with
um and there is much much less
information on the spreadsheet so
partial address name if available my
recollection is the amount was on there
although I've seen subsequent guidance
that suggest it's not always the the
case
um the warrant officer would then come
on the phone no longer physically
required to to come to court they would
come on oath they would read a fairly
template declaration to say that they'd
done everything that they needed to do
and they would then notify us if they
were withdrawing an application so
because the magistrates had so much less
information before them there was
basically no no grounds on which we
could then question a warrant and so
you're entirely reliant on the warrant
officer to withdraw applications and
then the the usual process the legal
advisor would steer you through the
presiding Justice would check that their
Wingers were happy and once they were
happy the the ones will be signed
electronically Ms eagle
thank you um once the process had
changed in the way in which you've just
described did you receive then any
further guidance on how to deal with
warrant applications or did you just
feel like you were administering a
process the uh the change was certainly
communicated by email but as is often
the case in in the courts your legal
advisor will brief you moments before
you enter the course and again in open
court as to what you need to be
satisfied of and and that would have
been the the norm in the moment the
legal advisor would have been taking us
through step by step but we needed to be
satisfied off but if if you as a
magistrate had concerns about an
application for a warrant or just had a
general concern that you're being asked
suddenly to okay A number that you
couldn't satisfy yourself about in the
way in which you had previously could
you ask for any more information about
an individual applicant could you put
one out of the list and say Mr blogs
what's what tell me about this this
application uh had I as a Winger asked
my presiding just is to do that my
presiding Justice would have asked me to
justify the grounds on which I was doing
that and if I had sort of made up a
requirement that I wanted to sample the
list on that basis I think that would
have been treated as a regular and
wouldn't have been allowed to go ahead
so no I wouldn't have been able to to
pick any address out am I right in
thinking that the um the guidance issued
at the same time as the bulk up load
procedure was introduced from the
national leadership magistrate Justified
these changes in the sense that advice
to justices hadn't kept up with the way
in which utility companies operate and
the rationale appeared to be that given
that um the utility companies weren't
enforcing entry to disconnect
that therefore the previous way of doing
things was disproportionate is was that
the rationale for this change in
guidance that is a retrofitted rationale
I would say so the the guidance that
you're referring to is an articulation
of uh the process that was issued just
this year so although the process
changed in 2019 that guidance came out
uh just earlier this year and you're
absolutely right and in that guidance it
makes for example no reference whatever
to the 500 to 600 000 people a year who
self-disconnect
I was going to make the point do you
understand what is the philosophical
difference between being disconnected
and not having enough money to put in
the meter to enable you to have
electricity or gas what is the actual
difference in practice that's it so uh
as far as the guidance issued is
concerned as far as the new process is
concerned uh the whole premise of this
is that the installation of a prepayment
meter is somehow trivial when compared
to disconnection but but in order to
come to that point you do have to be
willfully blind to the information that
is known that is published by offgem
that as I say up to 600 000
self-disconnect lack of money a key
reason and around half had experienced a
negative impact on health and mental
health as a consequence none of that is
reflected in the guidance to the courts
did it concern you that
warrant officer who you're not
on that front of you
um maybe in your case you said 50 to 100
cases at a time
um
how could you satisfy yourself obviously
they've taken an oath but you have no
way of checking on the process that
you've set out there that that person
has carefully checked through each case
to make the assertion that he can't go
behind the Earth really can you no you
have that there are there's no basis to
uh to question further and you see that
um in the the number of applicants
number one applications rejected so uh
on the moj's numbers in 2019 uh 1 824
applications were rejected in 2020 it
drops to 43 and it stays in double
digits despite the applications then
soaring in number
now Lord Justice Edith said in his
statement on the 6th of February when he
suspended any further consideration of
these warrants that magistrates relied
on the assurances made by all applicants
on oath that the supplier and their
agents have complied with the standards
set by off Germany went on to say that
off-gem themselves have now
reiterated concerns and that was his
rationale for suspending the um the the
the operation of these warrants or any
more warrants being applied for so what
was your understanding before then when
you were on the bench of course
of the nature of the assurances made by
all applicants for warrants on Earth
um so the applicants by the point that
they came on on the telephone they would
be uh declaring that they were a fit and
proper person appointed by the Energy
company or on on behalf
um that the company was compliant with
the supply license and it's really that
part that covers for example checking
whether or not customers are vulnerable
um that entry was reasonably required
under the legislation at that very low
threshold that they had to to hit have
been met and that the sums weren't being
contested and that some efforts had been
made to engage with the customer was
there any consideration about the
vulnerability of the of the um of the
people who were who who were whose these
warrants were being
signed up again the under the old
process that there may have been sort of
Clues if you like in individual
application so maybe an information on
the applications or to some degree you
might have been able to apply local
knowledge
um uh in order to raise those questions
um uh so you know and address might be
you know associated with particularly
vulnerable people but the um uh under
the the bow process no you would be
entirely reliant on the warrant officer
to volunteer that information thank you
thank you very much Mr Turner thank you
very much indeed so I think I'm writing
between July
2021 and December
magistrates granted a staggering I think
a staggering 536
139 of these warrants and refused I
think just 75.
why do you think that is
um I think if I may if you indulge me
for just a a moment I think the answer
to that is much more clearly articulated
in in the guidance that has been
referred to than than I could tell you
myself
um so the guidance that was issued to
the form of a q a
um and if I'm out I'll just quickly
rattle through some
um we always used to acquire them the
energy companies to prove more things
for example the date of last visit
there's no requirement in the
legislation for any personal visit at
all can the Justice refuse to issue a
warrant of the sum as less than 100 or
200 pounds if the applicant proves their
ground on oath normally you should Grant
the order as it would be irrational not
to do we need to know the sum demanded
in it in each case the amount is not a
relevant consideration when it came to
the sending of Human Rights letters once
the notice has been sent and no reply
received the court can be satisfied that
it is not opposed now in all sorts of
comparable procedures there would be
some recourse for somebody to say I did
not get that letter but not here I
believe the fees companies charge to fit
a prepayment meter too high can I refuse
to issue a warrant on these grounds in
general no what do we do if someone
turns up for the telephone hearing that
is a vanishingly remote possibility as
occupiers are not told the data location
and the hearings are not in public if by
some freak chance somebody did demand
admittance the Justice could either get
on with the case in private or put it
off so there should be alarm Bell
something about that I promise I'm
coming to an end very quickly how do you
check for conflict of interest uh
strictly speaking there probably isn't a
need to be concerned about this it could
be embarrassing for a magistrate to find
that they had issued a warrant against
their cousin fellow worker sworn enemy
Etc so research can be made on the names
is there an appeal not strictly speaking
what if the customer doesn't attend the
contested hearing
um by not by their absence it is clear
they are not contesting it and again
incomparable procedures we simply would
not take that as read
this is a reflection of a very strong
presumption that magistrates were simply
expected to perform a role really no
more sophisticated than an algorithm has
a properly constituted application being
put in front of me if yes approve
incredibly helpful I suppose you've
answered my next question which is why
in your experience you think so few of
these applications are actually
contested well I think the answer to
that is known to the courts I think the
answer lies in um a document that we're
all issued with called the equal
treatment fence book
um and uh it refers for example for
socially excluded people it says there
is a fear factor for many that are used
to having important decisions about
their lives made by others a failure to
attend a hearing for example may be due
to a chaotic lifestyle they may lack
what judges presume to be a natural wish
to come along and put one's case it
cannot be assumed that the individual
defendant is able it depends in this
context is able to understand legal
documents problems of understanding may
not be confined to the written word the
answers to why there are so few
contested applications are absolutely
known to the chords but are completely
thrown out in the guidance totally
ignored
thank you so you decided to go public
once you'd resign from the magistry
whilst you're serving as a magistrator
do you raise your concerns with the
call Clark's legal advisors or indeed
with
senior members of the Judiciary the
district judge yes so as I said I the um
as I said at the outset of my evidence
there were a number of interconnected
matters
um and so
um uh yes I for example
um uh raised concerns uh about changes
to victim surcharges which which are
affecting this group of people the most
vulnerable to society in exactly the
same way
um I wrote to
um I went personalized it I wrote to a
member of the magistrates leadership
executive around that well first of all
I raised it with my local elected bench
chair
um who was very diligent
um uh listened very closely but but that
role is simply not empowered to affect
change at speed in these kinds of things
but I wrote to the magistrates
leadership executive about
um it was actually about victim
surcharges but the reply that I got back
was our judicial oath requires us to
apply the Law whatever our personal
views might be and if a Judicial office
holder finds they cannot do that then
resigning is the appropriate course
now there are two parts to that the oath
requires us to apply the law which of
course is absolutely true as a
magistrate I believe in the in in in in
the rule of law
um but actually the oath is to do right
to all manner of people after the law
and it's within those words to do right
to all manner of people that I think the
judicial discretion uh lies and again I
emphasize there was no change in the law
there was a huge change in how
magistrates applied the law
um but also I think it's an indication
that you kind of you raise these matters
constructively politely in an
evidence-based way and the response is
well
you can always resign what do you think
is that response and did you change it
or response ultimately I took its advice
that that advice was given to me in in
June and I resigned in August
So based on your experience who's
responsible for identifying and
resolving problems with our process
operates within the magistrates Court
would you say the the normal people that
are a a magistrate would reach to would
be your bench chair
um who is represented on
um a number of bodies
um or you're absolutely right for some
of the roles that are actually being
abolished around Deputy justices clerks
and so on
um uh you might talk to there's also if
you'll forgive me there's also the the
magistrates Association and I should
acknowledge that I was never a member of
the magistrates Association it has
always seemed to me to be a a deeply
conflicted and and rather compromised
organization I think we need to go into
that yeah thank you
yeah just just getting
um back to some of the factual position
Mr Cantrell Feldick um did you notice
any change in the number of applications
refused uh before and after the change
in process in 20 19. yes absolutely so
under the old process I I would
personally have been involved in
rejecting some applications and under
the new one not at all
we've got some statistics which seem to
suggest in 2019 across the country
refuse
1824 out of two thousand two hundred and
seventy eight thousand odd um
by 2022 it's 56 refused it's a 98 drop
in one year yes okay and then just in
terms of the chronology of the matter
the bulk upload process is introduced I
think that's about September yep 2019
and the telephone process comes in uh
together with that at that stage there's
no additional guidance as to how you
deal with those matters coming from any
central body not that I recall that that
they're almost certainly as with any
significant change like that there would
have been an email
um but as is usually the case with a
procedural change in court you would
expect to be briefed on it moments
before entering the court and then the
legal advisor would do it absolutely and
as you say repeated in open court
exactly so big big cost of the open open
nature of Justice although yes uh but of
course bearing in mind that this actual
procedure happens not in open it happens
in court but not in open court it's not
open to the public effectively nobody's
going to be there indeed but it's just
stated for the record
just just
um
on a point of clarification I mean the
the statistics are up absolutely
baffling
you know 2019 as the chairs just
mentioned uh refuse 1824 total till
seven eight nine six six
and then basically it gets worse to now
in 2022 now that's 56 refused and the
total
um not being accepted as 367 thousand
one hundred and forty you see it that
it's not to change in the legislation
and and by the way I think our
presentation has been being fine uh it's
not a change in legislation so it's a
change in advice it's a change in advice
that magistrates would get the question
just for a point of clarification who
has got the power to change that advice
in what do you believe the the reason
was behind
changing that advice that have met the
huge difference and and the figures
which we've just explained yes and so
and I should say you know is it as a
sort of lowly Winger
um the the upper echelons of of the
Judiciary and and so on what would not
have been immensely clear to me but I
the my best guess my starting point
would be the magistrates liaison Group
which is the group where the senior
Judiciary and Senior representatives of
the magistracy meet to deal with matters
of policy and implementation I suspect
that is probably where this um
originated from
um as to the reasons why again uh I
can't speak to that in an evidence-based
way but my strong suspicion is this was
uh an innovation to deal with a rising
number of applications that threshold to
make a valid application is so low that
the volume was just going up and up and
up and my strong suspicion is that we're
doing conversations around right how do
we balance the interests of an efficient
process in the court with an efficient
process uh for the energy companies and
uh somewhere in that the interests of
the person the occupier got lost and
somewhere in that there was a
presumption built in that the energy
companies themselves could sufficiently
balance the interests of the occupier
and their own commercial interests that
they would be the people to exercise
restraint on whether or not to put a
warrant application in in the first
place and I think ultimately that that
expectation has been shown to be quite
naive
Miss David yeah thank you Chad hi Robin
Robin you mentioned victims surcharging
from what I understood from
fairy could you just say a little bit
more about that and how much that that
surcharge was or is extending victim
surcharge will deny to this though no
that's right so just to be clear
um uh in the course of 2022 there are a
number of areas where I was concerned
about if you like the most vulnerable
the first people in society and the
victim surcharges very tangential
um uh but but connected uh area so so
not directly related to this different
issue of concerned because there's no
victim in this case it couldn't be
Associated well you could debate whether
or not there's a victim in this not not
really in the terms of the legislation
indeed so he had a number of concerns
and that was another one of them um so
just send to to conclude we've got the
chronology of the change to the bulk
upload process in about September of
2019 uh we've indicated that through the
Court's processes you were revised of
that
um what we then know is that in December
um a journalist Mr Dean Kirby of the eye
ran a number of Articles how
highlighting uh what seems to be
potential injustices with this procedure
that has attracted the degree of
publicity and then I think you've
referred to the um
communication from the national
leadership magistrate Mr Webster
um that's in the form of a short
Preamble we have it and we'll make
arrangements for it to be published
in there next to our record of the
proceedings we refer to certain passages
In fairness it goes in our printout over
a number of pages indeed and it takes
the form of utility warrant frequently
asked questions and if uh quoted certain
extracts from that that I think was
issued in January of 2023. that's my
understanding of course by which point I
had left as a magistrate yeah
the logic of that there has to be that
that guidance of national leadership
magistrate is in fact a response to the
media coverage that have been generated
but uh earlier that year I believe it
says that explicitlynn 2022 yeah okay
thank you very much does anybody else
have any questions
this country if you permit me chairman
just very quickly I'm aware you're
starting time just to highlight that
obviously uh nobody in this process has
yet accepted wrongdoing at all the the
ministry of Justice said that people can
always contest these warrants we've
discussed that uh the senior Judiciary
said it was reasonable to rely on the
energy companies uh for the students
hmcts has been mute to the magistrates
leadership executive has been mute and
the ma we've discussed say magistrates
said nothing wrong and I think it's just
worth highlighting to you that nobody in
this process has yet accepted that what
happened was wrong which poses a very
real danger that when the media
attention moves on and the Parliamentary
attention must inevitably move on that
this snaps back to the way it was before
which would be a tremendous Injustice
I mean Lord Justice Ed is but probably
perfectly reasonably from a Judicial
point of view he says we relied upon
assurances I suppose the question mark
which we'll come on to later is the
reliability of assurances isn't it which
we can't help it in the in this panel Mr
contravenic very grateful to you for
your time and through evidence
and if we can now shortly uh have a
quick suspension masteries and move
around to the next panel of witnesses so
thank you for coming to help us today
um if you could just introduce
yourselves and your organization for the
record thank you chair my name is Debbie
Nolan I'm the managing director of avato
for Financial Solutions Mr Johnson Les
Johnson chief executive of Richmond's
okay now we've got some written briefing
on the on your two companies but just
for the record again and for those who
may be watching uh let's start with Mrs
Nolan and can you just explain the
nature of your business and what you do
for energy suppliers
supervised by the the FCA
as well as non-fca regulated Services
we're members of the credit services
Association and also active members of
the chart Institute Credit Management
thank you Mr Johnson
where debt collection agency work
uniquely for the energy companies I'm a
member of the CSA I'm sorry to spell out
the initials for those obviously don't
know but it Services Agency thank you um
we comply with their code of conduct and
go to practice
started doing this type of work I'm told
in about 2020 is that right
you know we've been undertaking
um these kind of activities uh since
around
2013 right so we started working for
British gas specifically in 2013. so
you've been doing work in the field but
then specifically um for British gas
Centric as it was a school at one point
in 2020. how was it that you came to
start doing that quite high volume of
work for for British gas so we had been
working with Regina since 2013 on a
number of different activities for debt
collection and we started a field
activity for them around 2017 2018
um in 2019 uh we were part of a a formal
process to uh for the for British gas to
Outsource all of their uh their live
management work so um so we took over
that contract at the beginning of
January 2020. he bid for the contract
and he was success it's part of that
Outsource Arrangement
um a hundred or so of the British gas
field agents moved into into our
environment I understand and do you do
work for any other energy companies
which are those we also undertake work
for um for OVO for EDF for Eon for
Scottish Power are there significant
differences
um particularly absolutely a size
Scottish Power because the legislation
may be different but are there
significant differences in the nature of
your contractual arrangements with those
other companies not
very different because it's a full
Outsource of the full process so that
the other organizations we provide
certain elements of the service there
are variations small variations in the
the types of things that we do but it's
predominantly it's the same
if it gets to the stage that an account
has got to the position over there being
an application for a warrant the process
will be pretty much the same it's very
similar yes each one of those
organizations has a different process
for checking at every stage whether or
not it's appropriate to move to a
warrant okay thanks thanks for watching
thanks for all that in a moment um and
then Mr Johnson
um am I right in saying that Richmond's
actually carrying out some work on
behalf of vivato that is correct and how
does that come about
um as have you been informed the vato
tended for the British gas contract so
that Richmonds we were not successful
um we subcontract visits not warrants
from arvato so we do pre-warrant visits
on behalf of arato on behalf of British
gas but not warrants okay and then you
would feed that information back to
avato yes that is correct and I assume
is known and that will be part of the
material you would need to assure the
court of in relation to the warrants is
that right so once a visit has been
providers and then they use that
information in their decision process at
the next stage I see okay and finally Mr
Johnson are there any other energy
suppliers that you subcontract for yeah
similarly
a number of Scottish party on
the utilita ETC but his visits again
rather than the actual no we do carry
out warrants on behalf of some of them
so which companies do you actually make
the applications for warrants um
Scottish Power
eon
Npower okay anything different in Broad
in general terms as to the practice
they're very much the same process that
we have to abide by okay pharah you'll
use what's now called the boat the bulk
upload process since August 2019 I
believe okay thank you very much Mr
David thank you chair um we're
interested in I'm interested very much
in the contracts you have with the
energy supplies and how that's
structured
um and obviously there's that
interrelationship working between
yourselves as well
um how are you paid for the services
that you are contracted to provide by
the energy suppliers
and for instance are you paid for each
warrant secured
and for each payment meter you install
so once we can start with you um Debbie
Nolan so so we don't install the
prepayment meters the energy provider
does we arrange for the warrant
application at that stage in the process
at the the at that visit
our agent will have the warrant and our
company buying an um an engineer from
the electricity or the inside for the
energy provider and a locksmith that the
energy provider has contracted as with
as well
right and are you paid for each warrant
that so if the commercials vary from
client to client
um and tend to be focused on the
activity that we've undertaken for
British gas it's very different because
we have an Outsource Arrangement they
were actually our first organization
that worked with us to create a
commercial structure that was focused on
the amount of time that it took to to
um to undertake a visit so the um there
is no incentive incentivization at all
for us to drive a certain outcome it we
spend as long as we need at the visit to
undertake the review that needs to be
done so how is that contract structured
then is let's say for British gas then
is it structured for each visit that you
do
so it's instructed on an hourly rate so
the amount of time that it takes us to
to undertake the visit and that allows
our agents then to spend more time
assessing whether or not there is any
vulnerability at the property whether
um there is anything that might impact
the installation of a prepayment meter
advise the customer if they're present
um when an account gets at this stage in
the process we would have already
undertaken a first visit either
ourselves or through Richmond's and at
that point the customer will have had
anything between 20 and 40 pieces of
communication from the energy provider
and three or four items of
correspondence from us as well we also
try to contact the customer by digital
messaging by email if we have those kind
of contact details
quite often we don't actually have the
name of the individual it's an occupier
because neither the energy provider or
us have been able to establish who's at
the address at the time so again A Pain
by the agent our time allows us to find
out the occupant if there's been a
change of tenancy and there are other
outcomes that can come at that point in
time
I've just so I'm clear so there'd be
ways in which you try to communicate and
the energy supplies will try to
communicate without face-to-face and
then you would gain the warrant and then
you would go and visit or you'd visit
the first established vulnerabilities
yes and then after that and so after at
that point we after the first visit we
send our information back to the energy
provider and then they make a decision
at that point when if necessary it's
appropriate to go to a warrant and
that's that will that will generally be
because we haven't been able to get a
conclusion at a first visit and quite
often that's because we haven't been
able to make contact still with the
customer and then if when you do gain
that warrant then you go back with the
energy supplies and then they put in the
meter so
and um and for yourself uh Liz Johnson
how does that work as well succinctly
explain the process
um the warrant is a final very final
part of that process prior to that the
Energy company may have attempted to
contact that customer 10 20 30 times by
means they adopt only when that is
filled there's a fail passed to Rich
Burns or another company
we are then charged with trying to
contact that customer we we write we
telephone we email we SMS ultimately we
visit
the purpose of that is to make contact
dialogue get information and feed that
back to the Energy company
in most cases we succeed
those files are passed back to the
Energy company we get paid for those
visits for that process we get paid to
do that
those files are then passed back to the
Energy company it is then up to the
Energy company to decide what it then
wishes to do
we will then for those that we work for
and we do warrants for receive files
back and be requested on behalf of the
Energy company to apply for the warrants
and you've discussed the process earlier
this morning we apply on behalf of the
Energy company for the warrant
if granted we will then action that
warrant
and on the basis of that action we will
be paid
by the Energy company that is how the
system works you get paid
a warrant that is granted is that how
you get paid or per application for a
warrant no we get paid for a warrant
being executed for carrying it out
as the warrants dismissed you don't get
anything for it yes and and if if
between the court issuing the warrant
and it is
um pool something happens we don't get
paid for that we only do get paid for
what we do on the door nothing else
okay are you under any contractual
obligation to adhere to the standard
license conditions yes absolutely with
every Energy company absolutely
both nodding like that and how do the
energy supplies that engage your
services monitor your compliance with
the standard licensed conditions we are
audited routinely and regularly by every
Energy company we have our own
compliance Department
so we operate the service level
agreement and must apply that to the
letter we are audited we are checked
that you have
how many corresponds would you say on
average that you would attempt to
achieve to make contact with the person
through both the pre-worn visits
pre-warrant there could be numerous
telephone calls numerous text messages
on average
on visits between one two maybe three at
the most visits and that's physically
going to the address and attempting to
make contact okay and correspondence
um one or two letters
probably asked off directly or do you
subcontract for some of the visits for
example
employed individuals who have around 180
employed field agents we do subcontract
a small element to self-employed agents
in areas with larger coverage such as
London for example and Mr Johnson yeah
similarly we we have self-employed
unemployed agents in relation to either
the employed or self-employed is any
part of their reward structure based
upon the number of warrants that are
secured all the number of meters
installed
result of that doesn't matter for our
bonus schemers as long as the visit has
taken as has gone ahead so there will be
no um additional bonus for an agent that
has a facilitated a pre-payment
installation than there is somebody that
walks away because they've identified a
vulnerability
would you have the visit before or after
the warrant
sorry I don't understand but the visit
takes place which they're rewarded for
where does that take place in relation
to the foreign
and Mr Johnson from your point of view
yes we incentivize our agents for a
positive outcome and the definition of
that is when you arrive at the door if
if you the customer agrees to pay or
part pay and make a payment arrangement
um there may be a change of tenancy
information that's what we incentivize
okay Mr James did you want to come in on
that point yeah
scheme for visits taking place if it is
someone's job to make those if
Philadelphia's job to make those visits
why do they need to be incentivized to
make them
it's just part of the the routine it's
quite um consistent with the rest of the
industry and our ages are paid a basic
salary and then there's an element of
bonus around that
at a per visit payment not not a bonus
depending on a number of visits for
example right so it's a per visit
it's intended to drive to make sure that
we um we make the visit and make sure
that we have recorded an outcome for
that visit that is appropriate thank you
if I made sure to come in on this point
the agent is incentivized to make
contact and get information or put the
customer in contact with the Energy
company that takes time so the longer
the agent spends at the door
um we we reward that does that that
makes sense yeah yeah it does keep
getting Mr Jess thank you um Debbie
Nolan can I just check I've understood
your answer so far correctly so you'll
be given a list of customers by British
gas or other energy suppliers you work
with you'll go to visit those customers
homes to do a pre-visit where you'll
check for any noticeable vulnerabilities
you'll record that information you then
send that back to British gas or the
other energy suppliers and the Energy
company gives you the go no-go decision
on whether to proceed with a warrant and
a forced installation is that correct
were you surprised when British gas
basically threw you under a bus and said
they were shocked and horrored by the
outcomes of the report and said it was
your fault
um that they would they were horrified
by the behavior of our agent that had
been reported in the Press um I I think
that that was the focus of uh of their
remarks rather than the surprise that
the visit had taken place because they
they check it at every single point
um before we go to the warrant so they
they and they send an engineer and their
locksmith as well so they know that the
visit is going um is is underway so my
interpretation of that reaction was more
around the behavior that had been
reported which bit of the behavior was
it the way they knocked on the door the
way they broke in someone's house the
way they nuzzled a dog the way that they
intimidated the people in the home the
way they installed the the prepayment
means to which bit of the behavior do
you think was a shock to British gas and
the shock was from the the uh the video
footage that was shared in the Press
which indicated that our agent was uh
excited by the um uh the the fourth
Century into the property you recognize
the British gas were at every visit so
they would have known what was happening
I just guess where
uh thank you what training requirements
do British gas put on you to train your
agents and how do you report back to
them that that training's been put in
place
well we we create our own training
within our business but we do share all
of that contact with our clients and
they also make sure that we are adhering
to all of those purposes in the same way
that that Les has just described us now
um by by way of audit
and just lastly do you have a key point
of contact at British gas please don't
give me their actual name but in terms
of their title is it a senior person a
junior person senior person what do you
know what the title is of the person's
role it's a
collections director title I think or
customer services apologies I don't know
it's a kind of director level role and
just very lastly briefly in terms of
your reporting back after you've done
each visit what information do you then
give back post installation about how it
went so we um provided an outcome code
which will reflect the result and that
could be that we've identified the uh
the New York events details we've
identified
um some vulnerability we've identified
um different things in the property um
and there's normally a narrative that
accompanies that that our field agent
has talked up on their handheld device
that we send back to the to the energy
provider thank you thank you thank you
thank you
um now between the 1st of January 2019
the 1st of December 2022 were Bartered
were granted almost 300 000 right of
Entry warrants and Rich burned
over 130 000 I'm just gonna come to each
of you in turn but these are huge
numbers huge numbers
um you at avato have said that you
handle 685 000 accounts each year for
energy providers in the information that
you've given to us
and eight to four percent of those
accounts are settled without the need
for a warrant which means 16 aren't
settled without the need for a warrant
and that's by a rough calculation
because I'm not quite sure
between which dates those numbers are
that's about 109 000 warrants this is a
significant number of warrants and
business that you're doing so how can
you establish the four you make
applications and how can you assure
yourself that you've established whether
there are any vulnerabilities that might
make it unsafe or impractical to install
a prepayment meter and actually put you
in breach of the law by doing so how do
you how do you satisfy yourselves about
that given the huge increase in numbers
that we're talking about here well they
have the energy providers have all of
that information they have the
information that we have collected if we
have anything from the first visit
um but in between our visit and their
next stage there may well have been some
interaction with their customer directly
we don't know that so we rely on the
energy provider providing us that
information we are applying for the want
on their behalf and therefore we're
relying on the information you don't see
it primarily as your focus to try and
discover this you just do what your con
what your the company you're working for
tells you to do leave all that to them
about vulnerabilities we
allow them to make the decision or rely
on them to make decision on the
information that they have as they are
the license holder so we are acting as
an agent on their behalf to apply for
the warrant once they have gone through
those checks and there are many checks
through that process it includes some of
our energy provider clients we we have a
checkpoint at the beginning of the day
we have a checkpoint when we're at the
property we have another checkpoint
poster visit so there's lots of
different variations on that 50
different clients
um Mr Johnson how do you satisfy
yourself uh in the same way about
whether or not there are vulnerabilities
um explain to you the pre-warn visit
process that is our opportunity when our
agent visits the premises once or twice
or maybe three times if they make
contact with the customer that is the
point at which we can identify
vulnerability
if we cannot make contact with the
customer we cannot report what we don't
know so we report that back to the
Energy company
when we receive the application for the
warrant and we go through the warrant
process and then we conduct the warrant
visit if when the officer arrives with
that warrant they identify vulnerability
they will report that to the Energy
company and walk away indeed that
happens in 25
of the warrants that we act action
we identify out the door and report it
to the Energy company it is only when
you make contact with the client that
you can identify if the client or the
customer does not make contact with the
Energy company or us we cannot report
what we don't know it's not that itself
a signal of vulnerability in many cases
no it's when someone's been attempted to
be contacted 20 30 times I I don't know
what we do about that that is what that
is the reality of what we deal with day
and day out as Nolan now what percentage
of uh how do you make sure that um there
are no vulnerable members of a household
when you haven't been able to establish
any contact
well one example is one of the articles
that was in the featured in The Press
was was an individual that um we hadn't
been able to establish contact with
before the warrant when we arrived with
the warrant we identified that the the
customer was was present she had three
children plus a newborn baby so our
agent walked away and that was reported
in that press article also so it happens
very regularly
um but please give us a slightly more
precise percentage or get back to us
with one I'm very happy to get back to
you with something realizing thank you
um in in carrying out so I mean you've
had three hundred thousand right of
Entry warrants between January 2019
December 2022.
um how can you can you give us any
figures about how many vulnerable
customers you identified out of of those
and therefore didn't proceed
and uh Mr Johnson you you're 130 000
sounds like you've got some figures in
your head already if you can say 25
suspiciously around number however but
nonetheless it is the fact it's a fact
okay it would be nice to have some
precise information from your Management
Systems about precisely how many
vulnerable customers were identified at
this stage because one of the concerns
that I certainly have is that the
vulnerability of the customer is not
actually being focused upon in the way
in which it ought to be and whether
that's your responsibility or the or the
license holder's responsibility the
companies you work for that nonetheless
is somebody's responsibility and so be
interesting to see see the figures that
you that you have
could I comment on the point that's just
been made because it might be helpful
um
almost half of the warrants we are
issued with uh we classify as walk away
we're doing action as things happen 25
of those we identify on visitors of
vulnerability it is around numbers yes
indoors that we carry out right um
uh if we as a collection agency we're
ignoring vulnerability at the doorstep
we would be flooded with complaints in
court cases they give you some accurate
figures last year we had 209 complaints
out of the numbers you've quoted 209
complaints do you understand however I
don't necessarily accept the premise of
what you're saying there which is which
is do you understand that part of
vulnerability in many instances is the
incapacity to act and therefore I don't
think it's fair to say that we'd be
flooded with complaints people just
think there's one more thing weighing me
down
um you know that is the concern and many
of people with vulnerabilities aren't
capable of acting for various reasons or
don't feel able to or aren't or don't
that is one of the concerns isn't it I I
can accept that point yet yeah okay now
you you refer
um Rich Burns you've given us um
a sequence of how you go through things
and you've referred to some of it today
you refer to um customers being sent to
Human Rights letter which informs them
of the application process what what's
in this human rights letter
it's a funny description for a letter
that you're sending to customers you're
about to we're required to do that that
is the regulation that we are required
to to act upon it informs the customer
of the situation and what they must do
uh and and the timetable what it asks
them to do is to make contact with us or
the Energy company again it's back to
what I explained earlier we're trying to
get dialogue communication that is how
most of these cases are resolved why do
you refer to it as a human rights letter
it
terminology that
that exists okay
I think can actually give a surprise
with an example yeah yeah very helpful
thank you
thank you very much um Mr Turner thank
you very much indeed
chair
you mentioned uh Mr Johnston been
answered to my colleagues questioning
that you'd be flooded with complaints
and you've answered that to a degree and
accepted what was put to you but you
also mentioned
uh you're be flooded with court cases
how do you propose
that one of the vulnerable people were
speaking about here
might bring an action against your
hugely powerful business
is that possible do you think
sorry I don't understand well a
vulnerable person who's having the door
smashed in
and one of these pre-payment meters
installed
against the will
how do you expect that vulnerable person
to take an action against your business
because I think that's what you said in
answer to questions from a colleague I
was just giving fights we don't smash
those in
firstly fourth Century don't you you
have a warrant to enter the property
lawful and against well lawfully I
accept
but against the will of the occupant of
that property you install a meter by
virtue of that we can assume those
persons are vulnerable how do you expect
those vulnerable people to bring an
action against your big business
I can't answer that obviously I cannot
answer that question
you cannot or you don't want to answer
it no it's I I can't answer it you're
asking me the impossible I can't answer
for every individual okay let's move on
then when you apply for a warrant
how do you decide which court to use
that's either of you
know we are nominated a bulk report
which is uh Portsmouth
sorry again we are assigned a court
right and who signs that to you um I'd
have to say I don't know I need to check
you don't think it might have been worth
asking the question if you're assigned a
call this is a court system that assigns
it to his hmcts sorry emergency schools
for tribunal service I think so I think
so
and who applies for the warrants
we apply the the the collection agency
applies on behalf of the Energy company
and what information your agents has to
attest to under oath
that uh all the checks the prescribed
checks have been carried out and we
haven't not at that stage that
identified any vulnerability just
just remind us again what are those
prescribed checks that you talk about
um that we have sent the human rights
letter we have visited we have attempted
to contact the debt is legitimate and
valid
and that we have not identified any
vulnerability or any other reason that
we should not apply for the warrant
and I think I'm right in saying in
September
2019 the system changed to the bulk
upload procedure
for the warrants
how did that affect your approach if at
all
could it affect your approach to the way
you do your business
um it certainly hasn't affected approach
in terms of the the checks that we
undertake before
before we go to that warrant application
I will answer the same yeah
after warrants obtained what further
steps are taken before prepayment meter
is forcibly
installed
prepayment meter is not installed in
every single warrant I may have a
statistic for you in terms of the
prepayment meters
um
it is only a percentage of the warrants
actually carrying out what ppms are
fitted in our case Richmonds of all the
files we receive right from the very
beginning it is less than four percent
prepayment meters fitted yeah the same
foreign
how many prepayment meters did you uh
forcibly install in 20 22.
in uh the rich ones would have fitted
about 14 and a half thousand from
knowledge 14 and a half thousand
yes so my numbers are fifty eight
thousand since twenty twenty fifty eight
thousand since twenty twenty but we
don't fit the prepayment meter our
energy providers to do that we arrange
for the warrant
how do you ensure that your agents
comply with the standard license
conditions on vulnerability and safety
we receive instructions from our clients
that set that out specifically so that
we can make those checks there are a
number of checks along the process to
make sure that everything has been
covered and checked
in terms of the times investigation
which you'll be no doubt familiar with
yeah
you read that those reports yes you took
a proper interest in that no doubt
now that report suggested that agents
had acted in breach of the standard
license conditions relating to
government customers vulnerability uh
vulnerable situations rather
do you agree with that
no because the uh if in one of the cases
that was reported in the Press was
specifically around an individual who
who clearly had a vulnerability but we
identified that on the visit and then we
walked away so that is that's exactly in
lines with the conditions
it must have been upsetting for you to
be criticized by those that were
instructing you
British gas attire what British gas at
that point did not know that that
customer had any vulnerability that we
were aware of the first time any of us
had managed to make contact with her
tell me Debbie Nolan what
what is the most rewarding part
of your business
the most rewarding part is that we do
get plenty of thank yous from
individuals and customers who have found
that the visit to their property has
been helpful to them as has been
mentioned earlier sometimes
um people particularly in vulnerable
situations aren't able to make telephone
calls or understand letters so that's
the first initial visit is actually very
helpful to some people plenty of thank
yous yes
Mr Johnston
um I wouldn't say the thank yous but we
do resolve most of the cases as I said
to you it's less than four percent that
goes to this extreme level
um a lot of it gets resolved well before
through the processes that I've already
explained we don't just turn up with a
warrant that is a long tail to it
thank you Jeff can I just ask you yeah
yeah one two people want to come in Mr
Brown will cut my iPhone
thanks here um I was going to ask about
the numbers of prepayment meters and it
seemed to be natural there so well as
you said four percent of one application
is without an installation of prepayment
mirrors four percent of all the files we
receive ends up less than four percent
that we go to how many of the one
applications of the 130 000 then don't
payment meals I've given you that
figures
last year right
and so David can you say how many of the
one applications end up
percentage-wise and installation of
prepayment mirror is that same four
percent
because you said 58 000 prepayment years
were that was
the math factors you applied for 285 000
warrants from 2020 so that's 20 surely
end up prepayment years for our vato
rather than four percent yeah so four
percent of all of the accounts that we
receive this four percent of the
accounts that we receive
as Mr Johnson explains what 20 warranty
applied for an adult prepayment mirror
has been sold in I don't have that
number to hand but I can absolutely
confirm that to you
Mr they written them was was eating
thanks just very briefly I'm I'm
absolutely amazed what uh what I've just
heard by the way
that you know both Mr Johnson and Ms New
Orleans suggesting that the one of the
the best parts of the the job is thank
you let us from
um some of the most vulnerable people in
in our communities the fact that they're
doing smash the doors down Mr Johnson
I'm I'm pleased to hear that but I'm
sure you haven't got keys to get in and
I'm sure that people don't welcoming in
open the door and say come in and put
the meat away you might want it these
are the most vulnerable people in our
communities that's why your companies
are making fortunes from the energy
companies who in turn on the fortunes uh
at a time where people can barely put
their bread on the table because of the
cost of living crisis and yet you're
sitting in front of this committee
suggesting that the most rewarding part
of the job is to thank you let us you
get from individuals I just find that
absolutely unbelievable I just leave it
there it's more comment than the
question but if people want to come back
can I have a sponsor yeah of course um I
did not say that was the most rewarding
part I did not say that we do not smash
doors in
how do you know
most
we enter with agreement from the
customer as we don't smash doors in
otherwise you've got a locksmith yes I
think that's great I see yeah right
um we need to come towards the end of
this topic um
I just I just um I wonder given that
um since uh Lord Justice Edith a senior
presiding judges put a stop to warrants
being granted at the moment in the
courts because off-jammers become
sufficiently concerned at the operation
of suppliers to ask all energy companies
to suspend forced installation
um are you conducting retrospective
checks to establish how many prepayment
meters have been installed in the homes
of customers with vulnerabilities are
you doing that Debbie Nolan we we can
certainly look into the accounts where
we know a prepayment meter has been
installed and and review the account to
see if there has been any vulnerability
identified at any stage of the process
um no are you are you going back
retrospectively and looking where you've
been stalled the meter whether or not
there are vulnerabilities not are you
checking your files to see whether you'd
identified
that's why I'm asking answering that
right you are you are present when the
meter is installed yes and because you
are executing the warrant so are you
doing any retrospective checks where
there is a a meter installed has British
gas asked you to do any retrospective
checks on vulnerability so British gas
is asked us to provide us all the
information that we have on our accounts
and that includes any information that
we have on vulnerability that we have
sent to them so yes that is just
providing them with information they've
already had during the process that is
not a retrospective check on
vulnerability where a meet has been
installed is it
but it depends on your assessment for
vulnerability because it's very it's
very difficult to assist that
retrospectively because quite often it's
transient and there's different things
that happen that we aren't aware of
because it's on our client system we can
only answer the information that we have
on our files but we're very happily
sharing that with our clients including
British gas so you you would say that by
providing extracts or the whole copies
of your existing files that amounts to a
retrospective check to establish if
there's vulnerability would you is that
the very start of the process yes to
understand it yes but as far as you're
aware is there any proactive work going
on to go to places where these meters
have been installed and check whether
the people there are vulnerable my
understanding is that that is that is
underway at the moment we are not doing
that we're not doing that but it is
happening we have been instructed by
British gas to return all of their
accounts and not to act on their behalf
at the moment so at the moment we are
not doing anything for finish gas I
understand and Mr Johnson
the same question to you if I may help
um we have not been asked by any Energy
company to do to to do what you suggest
nor will we have the information the
information once we the warrant is
executed that relationship is between
the customer and the Energy company so
you wouldn't be able to do that we
wouldn't be involved beyond that point
no okay if that helps the final thing um
if a prepayment meter is installed
what's the typical cost of enforcement
that gets passed on to the customer can
I help with that
I don't know that I'm afraid sure
it should be quite an important bit of
information to have in your records
wouldn't it
it wouldn't be us that applies that
charge to the customer energy provider
okay okay uh
same with yeah the Energy company yeah
the very last one Mr because then we
need to hand over thank you chair so
after several visits
um the vulnerable single mother very
often allows your agency to fit the
meter or indeed a locksmith doesn't
smash the door down but
forces entry and fits the meter that's a
costly process isn't it
do you not bother to make the inquiry
about how much of that cost is passed to
the consumer
do not bother to ask those that instruct
you
how much of that cost is passed on to
that vulnerable person
do you not do that
why not
why ever not the best of my knowledge I
I believe the fear is 150 pounds but I
would have to confirm that in writing to
the committee on if you could do that if
that's the thing those vulnerable people
are writing to you to thank you about
eager to confirm that to us just
know that
uh well Mr Johnson was able to give a
figure can you
um I I can't but I can if you can find
out come back to us then we will thank
you for your evidence very grateful to
you uh and um we'll now suspend briefly
to um hand over the chair to Mr James
thank you very much for coming uh
welcome back to this Joint Committee
hearing of the justice and business and
energy committee on forced installation
of prepayment meters we're now welcome
uh Chris O'Shea chief executive of
centrica the owner of British gas and
Bill Bowen uh the chief executive of uh
utilita
um Mr O'Shea at first as I understand it
the license license conditions that
off-gen place upon you
state that you can only forcibly install
a prepayment meter if it's quote safe
and reasonably practical in all the
circumstances to do so and the guidance
from the regulator says that the
supplier should assess each individual
case on its merits do you acknowledge
that yes
um the same guidance goes on to say that
the warrant must not be used where such
action would be severely traumatic to a
customer due to an existing
vulnerability which relates to that
person's mental capacity or
psychological state which will be made
significantly worse by the experience do
you acknowledge that yes
the times reported that British gas
agents broke into the home of a young
mother with a four-week-old baby who
alongside her seven two and one year old
child was crying and rocking her newborn
baby whilst your agents tried to
forcibly fit an electricity meter that
she knew would automatically disconnect
because she couldn't afford to pay her
energy bills
that case the British gas presumably
signed off was that in compliance with
your license conditions Mr ashay
especially if I meet here that case
reported by the media did not result in
a prepayment meter being installed that
case was a customer that we had made
around 50 attempts to contact including
a home visit where there was no answer
a customer that hadn't made a payment
since November 2021 who owes over three
thousand pounds of energy debt continues
to run up there to the rate of 160
pounds a month as soon as the agents saw
that there was a vulnerability the
newborn baby they walked away they
identified the vulnerability which I
think is exactly in keeping with the
licensed conditions thank you it was
also reported that British gas agents
broke into the home of a woman in her
50s with known severe mental health
problems and bipolar disorder was that
case in compliance with your license
conditions I don't have the details of
that case it was also reported that
British gas broke into the home of a
woman registered as partially cited and
disabled with known arthritis and
Mobility problems was that case which
was also signed off by British gas in
line with your license conditions again
I don't have the details of that case
you don't have the details of individual
cases but you acknowledge do you Mr
O'Shea that somebody at British gas has
to sign off on each and every visit to
somebody's home to break in and forcibly
install a prepayment meter
process that we follow at first is on
average we make 24 attempts to contact a
customer before we apply for the warden
and if it might help I would say in 2022
we applied for 92 we're applying for
immigranted ninety two and a half
thousand warnings
of the 92 and a half Thousand Ones
immediately upon being granted those
warrants we write to the customer to let
them know it has been applied thirty
four thousand of those warrants resulted
in a resolution either the customer
acknowledged the day entered into
prepayment plan there been a change of
tenancy the customer of the way we
identified the vulnerability because as
you previous witness said
vulnerabilities are transient and can
change or we had a customer who
voluntarily asked for a prepayment meter
of the remaining 58 000 we installed 20
469 prepayment meters under one we had
12 000 customer cases which resulted in
payments we had 4 000 customers where we
identified the vulnerability after being
awarded the warrant and walked away
so it sometimes is not possible to
identify a vulnerability because
customers who simply refuse to engage if
we identify a vulnerability
we don't install speed payment meters
now we have an independent investigation
going on just now often we've also
launched I'll come down a second mystery
if that's okay we'll talk about
follow-up actions um in a moment it was
reported that there were Excel
spreadsheets that your agents of Auto
had where customers were listed their
vulnerabilities were noted and that
information was circulated to all field
agents on a weekly basis and we just
heard from avato your bailiffs that
somebody at British gas had to give to
go no-go decision on each and every case
who in British gas gave the go no-go
decision to enter into all the homes
I've just had a customer debt collection
the head of customer debt collection and
sorry on that just to be clear
we will issue sometimes to the debt
collection agency I proceed with caution
notice where we suspect there may be a
vulnerability but we're not sure so
we're quite clear on that now that would
be if you see a spreadsheet which says
there may be a vulnerability again
vulnerability can be transient I would
also say that the off-gen definition of
vulnerability applies to the customer we
apply that definition to the household
so we have a we have a procedural policy
which is more stringent than the off gem
definition okay but if we suspect
there's a vulnerability we'll let the
debt collector know but we can confirm
that if we can't make contact with the
customer first your head of debt
collection uh management a British gas
that signs off on these cases who does
that person report to in British gas in
terms of your compliance with its
license conditions would report to the
head of customer operations who reports
to the head of British Gas Energy and at
what point does that get to board level
the British you have the way that we
operate within Centric as we have eight
separate business units Each of which
have a managing director and we have a
compliance reports we have uh an audit
and risk committee and the way that it
would work is that the British Gas
Energy would have compliance reviews and
would identify risks and those risks if
they're material for the group would
then find their way on to the group risk
register the signing off of the
application for warrants does not come
to the board it does however go through
and the head of Regulation which sits in
the general counsel's department but it
wouldn't come to the central board so
I've got the terms of reference here for
your order and risk committee and it
sounds very reasonable it says there's a
number of internal audits done on a
quarterly basis there's quarterly
reports that a group risk management
function that those internal Auditors
are checked and that there is a review
uh to highlight any material risks and
incidences of non-compliance with your
sector-specific legal and Regulatory
obligations
all of the cases that have been reported
and these only some of them
are to me a very clear breach of your
license conditions that would be a
material risk that ought to be reported
at your audience risk committee has a
paper ever gone to your audit and risk
committee to discuss these types of
breaches firstly I would see each year
of the to pre-judge the outcome of
either the off-term investigation or our
investigation been behind just giving
you my view Mr ashay I asked if it's
ever been reported to your audience you
know I understand but I think the
premise of your question is that there
has been a breach the investigation will
establish whether it's been a question
is whether there's been a report to your
audit and risk Committee of a bleach and
my point is that that has not yet been
established whether there's been a
breach my question very specifically has
there ever been a report to your audit
and risk committee that has dealt with
the issue of forced installation of
prepayment meters by British gas yes or
no so there has been a discussion at the
Centric award last year about the whole
issue of prepayment meters after the the
reports in the eye newspaper referred to
before to the best of my knowledge has
been no report to the audit and risk
committee because we have not yet
identified the reach the first the
potential breaches came to my attention
was in the media reports they've
launched an investigation that will go
to the Centric of audit risk committee
but because there'll be no established
breaches right now there's been no
report to the other committee to the
best of my knowledge and surprised it
but the first you heard about it was the
time story I mean there's been lots of
news reports over many many years
including to be fair before the time you
were with British gas of the company
forcibly installing prepayment meters
and indeed in 2018 just before you
joined uh the board as I think Chief
Financial Officer off gem issued a
warning to British gas for having a rate
double the industry average and had said
that you needed to bring that number
down it's actually gone up very
significantly so the business British
gas has known for many many years that
this is a concern of the regulator about
the forcible installation of prepayment
meters by the business so I'm I'm
confused as to why you've only just
kind of encountered this issue because
of the times exposing this looks like a
systemic issue with British gas to
always be reported on isn't it mostly
the data that you have is incorrect the
number of prepayment meters installed
under Warren has actually reduced for
British gas in 2019 it was 23 000 in
2020 it was 8 000 in 2021 it's twenty
one thousand and in 2022 it was 20. so
one of the highest in the sex right 469
we're the largest Energy company in the
sector you've also got to bear in mind
that the number of the rate per customer
you're still the highest user of these
though aren't you
no because we have 1.2 million
prepayment customers we have another 6.3
million customers who we afford credit
to now a lot of those prepayment
customers are there because their
voluntary prepayment customers you will
have companies that have no prepayment
customers and you'll have companies that
have only prepayment customers so you've
got to look at what we would call the
Social uh economic mix of the customer
book but the numbers of installations by
British gas has actually come down in
that period
are you concerned that your internal
audit compliance and risk reporting
is inadequate if these issues have not
been escalated to you previously given
that you seem to know nothing about it
one of the things that I was most
disappointed about and the reason that I
was very upset with the media reports
was we had actually had an internal
audit team out with our vato
um weeks before those reports and had
identified no issues so this is not the
installation of prepayment meters under
one it's not something that came to my
attention a result of the media reports
the allegations that there was improper
behavior is what came to my attention
through the media report and what we
immediately did upon that was to suspend
work with alvato and to launch an
investigation to establish the facts to
understand whether the instances we saw
reported were isolated or systemic now
that report is ongoing just now I think
it's very important that we understand
um from the cases have been reported but
also from a statistically significant
sample whether there is a systemic issue
the problem we have Mr to say is that
avato said they just did what you told
them to do and you're saying it was a
vato's problem that these issues have
happened and we seem to be going around
in seconds so we'll look forward to
reading your report just lastly for me
at this stage um if you were so sad
about this story uh how much of your
three billion pounds in profits have you
allocated to compensation for the
victims of your actions
so firstly on your previous comment
arvato are a subcontractor centrica
the British gas so this is not around
going in circuit I think that your
assertion is is a bit unfair the
entitled to my view Mr I asked you a
question today how much you've got three
billion pounds in profits have you
allocated to compensation to the victims
of your actions
again at the risk of repeating myself I
think it's important we establish
exactly what's going on here if
if you permit me to finish if we
identify that we have acted incorrectly
have been very clear we will make that
right
I can only answer that question when we
have the results of our investigation
okay so I'm clear at this stage
irrespective of all the testimony the
story and the evidence you're saying to
this committee that you're not admitting
that British gas has had failings in the
forced installation of prepayment meters
I need to see the result of it that's
astonishing as an Administration given
the stories of real situations that have
been reported and you're here today
saying that you don't know whether those
are legitimate stories not these were
real people that reported in real time
by an investigative journalist with your
employees and your agents causing
enormous amounts of distress to them and
you're not even acknowledging that that
was something that happened so to cheer
I think that's a misrepresentation of
what I'm saying one of the cases that
was reported by the media is an
individual that we had attempted to
contact in many occasions we actually
don't know the name of the person
they're a tenant in the property we
install the prepayment meter that was
reported by the media that person has
not complained we still cannot make
contact with that person we don't know
their name however with the prepayment
meter installed they have started to
reduce their debt this is a very very
difficult situation that we're in which
is in any other industry if we afforded
credit to people that we knew couldn't
pay that would be a breach of our
business in potential license conditions
so we're caught in a very difficult
position but I'm not saying that it's
clear that nothing has gone wrong what
I'm saying is we need to have a proper
investigation and often these are very
complex debt Pathways they take months
and average it takes about six months
before we even apply for a warrant we
have to go back and check all of that
we're checking the Rover we've got 20
people working in this we'll get
external advisors working on it as well
there's 150 documents they're going
through we need to trace every every
step in the path to make sure whether we
got it right or wrong not just for the
cases identified but for the hundreds of
additional random samples that we've
taken probably should have allocated
those resources to doing it right in the
first place do you regret that
I can't see at the moment whether this
has not been done properly thank you Mr
butlin just to very briefly Pro open to
colleagues off gem the regulator did a
compliance review of these processes and
remarkably British gas was the only only
Energy company that came out saying
there were no issues with their
processes and your business utility was
at the bottom of the ranking is saying
severe weaknesses if this is happening
at British gas what on Earth is
happening at utilita and if it's not a
problem why did off gem say that which
compliance review you talking about this
is the market compliance review in
September 2022.
about current debits about the fourth
installation of prepayment meters and
how vulnerable customers are being
treated
so and they they divided the suppliers
into four brackets no significant issues
British gas minor weaknesses a whole
list of others moderate weaknesses a
whole list of others severe weaknesses
true energy utility and Scottish prayer
you must know what I'm talking about
yeah
um off-chemist carried out a number of
Market compliance
reviews during the year
I'm I'm aware of that and we were very
unhappy with that result you know I
think the practicalities of situation
are you know that actually we have a
very good process fundamentally we have
the same difficulties as British gas in
contacting customers
um obviously we have a large number of
customers that have
um you know financial difficulties
because we specialize in doing prepay
but because we uh actually special
specialize in doing smart prepay
um I think you find that the the
experience of customers is very
different
the which consumer organization just
published a report recently that ranks
suppliers
um we didn't come top octopus did as
they often do but we came second and for
a company that's got 90 of its customers
prepay I think you find that's a pretty
good result so I'm was disappointed with
that review by often I was also
disappointed with the review that they
did into direct debit payments which I
found was equally inaccurate based on
the the objective information that often
had available
um but obviously I don't run off Jim so
that's the important point I just want
to try to um flesh out a bit so off gem
found that you were one of the worst
suppliers whereas British gas is one of
the best suppliers but as I've just said
out reddish gas's actions as far as it's
been reported were completely inadequate
but your assessment I think is what
you're saying is that the way in which
off gem assessed outcomes
was not
good enough
that would be the conclusion I would
come to but I mean I don't know because
I wasn't you know privy to exactly what
went on and off gym all I can talk about
the outcomes that we have for customers
and we process something like two and a
half thousand
um warrant installations they didn't all
end up as a warrant installation but
we've you know we've got evidence where
we've aborted and installed because of
the vulnerability turning up at the last
minute but as I say you know the key
difference with utilita is that we don't
install dumb prepay meters and as has
already been said vulnerabilities are
transient and
um where a vulnerability turns up post
that installation we have the ability to
switch a customer back into credit mode
which is something that we do all the
time hundreds per week we switch back
into credit mode and some hundreds per
week are being switched into prepay mode
or at least were until the suspension
okay thank you Alan Brown please yeah
thank you chair
um
just wondering if you can say out
exactly how you're going to interact
with arvato structured but also if you
start at the beginning before we'll get
to the awful end point where people are
getting forced
get involved
so the the contract structured with the
matter where we have a full Outsourcing
of our debt collection but what we do is
we identify obviously we know customers
they're paying customers that don't pay
so we will identify customers and they
don't pay we will make attempts to get
in touch with customers
when those fail then we pass that one to
our vato again how do you have our last
of those who don't pay so
we just we monitor accounts right so
these are these are for customers
because obviously when prepayment meters
um we monitor that differently but for
customers that either pay by direct
debit the direct debit is canceled or if
customers be what we call cash checks
we've got the two million customers that
do that and if they get a bill and then
they've not paid it within their terms
we don't immediately pass it on to the
debt collectors we're trying to get in
touch with the customer
um what we're always trying to do we
offer payment plans a lot of payment
plans up to five years
we'll pass this on where we the customer
is simply not engaging with us or where
the debt gets gets quite aged when
they're about to get involved then
would be the point where we think that
there is a problem with actors actually
getting paid with the customer so we
would then pass that on tarvato and it's
not it's not really Advantage will do
debt collection but it's not just about
the installation of prepayment meters
about the recovery of debt
nothing from British gas saying the
bill's now overdue
but I got an email from arvato
looking for payment now I checked
with it was when I go in line and I
checked with the bill that was created
and when British guys saying the bill
was due by Arvada or send an email
within the calendar month so that
doesn't suggest to me that proper checks
are going on in the British class are
engaging and doing stuff before that to
a parts for their agency and I know it's
not good for people watching outside the
room I'll give pass to another email
so that's email I've received from
arvato
if you want to look at it it doesn't
reference a gospel once it doesn't
reference a bell at all
it tells me to visit a secure rise
notification with a link now when I see
that I think that's a fishing email I
think that's a scam there's nothing
there that suggests a guy spell nothing
says it's overdue there's telephone
numbers there's nothing there but
circumstances vulnerabilities or
anything so do you think that's
acceptable in that part your contract
with vato I mean if people are receiving
emails like oh it's no wonder they're
not engaging Mr I'm going to have to
take this away and understand exactly
what happened in the process in the face
of it that email is not a good email I
mean I know that that's about your gas
bill because I can see your customer
number I don't expect you to remember
your customer number for your gas bill
but I'll need to go away and look into
that that's to start the process where
British class and arvato that's the
start of a day been possibly been added
to customer accounts isn't it well no
because the consumption of gas and
electricity by you and your flight is
what adds the debt this isn't this is
not what adds to the debt so the
question is no fee from arvato then
sorry
I mean the question previously was about
the cost of the of the meter
installation it's 150 pounds we charge
56 pounds the customer on Grant the one
and 94 pounds on the installation of the
meter the payment for this that's that's
that's sort of our account but I would
like to look into this
um did you raise anything with British
gas when this happened
there's no chance to the customer for
this and if customer gets in touch if
the Bill's not come through or there'd
be no reminder then then clearly there's
an issue and we fixed that that's not
the case actually passed the debt
collection agency so from then on
they're going to be chasing and chasing
and they're clearly then current fees
that are going about it to the account
no it's not the fees are the the fees
that were will be added to the to the
account would be
um when we've been through the 150
pounds which is not a true reflection of
actually the cost of doing this that's a
cap that off gem have put in place I
think that was put in place in 2017 but
now there'll be no there's no cost to
you for that will start chasing up as
dead collection agency and there's no
fees in court to the customer we we pay
for that because
either we have an in-house team this is
part of surgeon's customer so either we
have an in-house team or we have a team
that's outsourced that cost is is for us
we're allowed to recover 150 pounds
where we install it we don't recover
that in every case where we identify
severe Financial vulnerabilities
outsourced so as the previous witness
said we've outsourced our entire debt
collection uh to arvato we have a team
in town who monitor that we have three
full-time colleagues and it's part of
the the customer collections team that
the full activity for collecting debt
has been outsourcedure
and the money that has added to
customers bills once we got our
prepayment meter
I'm forcibly installed how how long do
they get to pay that back so on average
customer's paying back all the debt that
they would have in a paper because
obviously with the customers we install
a prepayment meter for under one on
average it was more than a thousand
pounds the average repayment rate is
five pounds a week it can be as low as
three pounds 25 and this would simply be
added on to that
that's 150 pounds you said so it's hard
to do but unless there's severe
Financial vulnerability and then we
don't challenge it we absorb that
ourselves
thank you um can I just clarify
something briefly earlier uh Mr Shay you
gave us numbers about Force installation
of prepayment meters can I just check
There's no distinction between going in
and installing a prepayment meter
and installing a smart meter that's
later converted to a prepayment meter
was it inclusive of all of those actions
so so the numbers
um so the 20 469 number that I gave you
for people have been installed last year
there's an additional six thousand which
is called business driven mode change
which was a change from our
um it's a smart meter changing from a
credit meter to a prepayment meter
there's six thousand on top of the
numbers yeah to twenty six and a half
thousand yes okay thank you Mark Jenkins
then please indulge me that was one of
the questions I had and I'm not sure
that you actually answered the question
that Mr Jones asked
the number that you gave about
prepayment installations you've then
added another 6 000 on which were more
change
afterwards
there are circumstances in which you
would enter a property install a smart
meter potentially in credit mode
um for that more change to take place
afterwards not forcibly no so we
wouldn't solve it would always be a
prepayment you would leave the property
in prepayment mode on every occasion
that I mean that's unless there's unless
there's a mistake yes because customers
would have would go from what are called
dumb meters to Smart Meters
they have to agree to that and so
um it's part of our off-gen mandate that
we need to reach a certain number of
customers but no we would never forcibly
enter a customer's premises to achieve
an old what we call a dumb credit meter
for a smart really circumstances it
would always be left in prepayment mode
unless it was a mistake like you said
yeah because because the idea of
breaking into customers home or forcibly
entering a customer's home
change a dumb credit meter for a smart
credit meter I I just I can't think of
how that would ever would ever occur the
other number just in terms of the number
of we installed just under 100 000
prepayment meters last year more than 70
000 were voluntary at the request of
customers so when you look in total
we've got twenty thousand installed
under warrant we've got the six thousand
business driven mode change which we're
no longer doing and another 70 000 that
were installed at the request of
customers I'm I'm sorry if I might just
check at the request of customers I I
used to
work in a business where I had to read
customer ordered Journeys for call
centers and often it was the advice of
the company agents to the customer so
can I just be clear when you say at the
request of the customer what that
actually means I think is that the
British gas call center person has
called somebody and said we need to sort
out your ability to pay your bills we
recommend you move on to a prepayment
user is that right no because you could
have lots of landlords who want to have
a preposition somebody will buy a buy to
let property and they want the majority
of people are domestic customers they're
paying their own bills though aren't
they I mean do you really have the data
that suggests how many customers ring Up
Ring you up and say please move me to a
prepayment meter that costs more to run
and which will disconnect the
electricity from my house I'm sorry the
prepayment meter doesn't cost more to
run the prepayment electricity under the
prepayment meter is the cheapest
electricity on the market today gas is
slightly more expensive but they it's
it's a misconception that there's a
premium on
[Music]
a large premium when they say gas is a
bit more expensive electricity the
cheapest electricity you buy in the
market today is under the prepayment
meter but you've not answered my
question how many customers practically
call you up and ask without the advice
of your course Center agents to be moved
on to a prepaid I don't have that number
I suspect that's probably close to zero
isn't it most people would rather just
stay on Earth well on on the
um again your assertion that the
majority are owner occupiers I'm not
sure is born out by the data of the 20
000 people that we installed more than
four thousand were in vacant properties
um we do have people that will buy to
let landlord will attend in my
experience to prefer to have a
prepayment meter so if there's a
property purchased they want a
prepayment meter because they don't want
to be liable for that but I don't have
the numbers to hand but I just thought
it was important I just wanted to
clarify your language because I'm not
I'm not sure I I fully buy it but I'm
sorry to interact Mark so you give me a
segue into another uh follow-up question
from from early before I get into what I
really want to ask
um
you talked about 1.2 million um
prepayment questions
which I think you said were voluntary
and Mr Bullen talked about switching
between credit and prepayment quite
regularly I think now some years ago
more years ago than I care to remember
and before your time certainly
Associated I was a uh moved into a house
that wasn't a new house to Whisper had
been letting had prepayment meters
um and was with British gas who then
wanted from a young couple who were in
full-time employment with credit
good credit written wanted 800 pounds to
take out prepayment meters and move on
to credit which you know the supplied on
at no charge
um how easy is it for customers to move
from prepayment into credit I mean given
that was probably 20 years ago
I mean it's if customers pass the credit
check then as long as we think customers
can afford to pay then uh it's it's no
problem at all I I don't have any
knowledge of the 100 pound charge I mean
I think practices were quite different
all that time ago but you know I mean
ultimately
it what we want is something where the
customer can pay because whilst it's
really difficult for
um customers going to prepayment meters
is also a significant contributor to
mental ill health people running up
debts that they can't pay so this is an
incredibly difficult situation
prepayment meters are currently
um very much in in the press in in the
media and there's a general perception I
think that they're
um that they're they're really not the
right thing to have but 20 years ago
when I was this guy I remember people
being disconnected the installation of
prepayment meter as distasteful as some
people might find that has reduced
substantially the number of people that
used to just get cut off and be left
with no gas and electricity
thank you sorry I'll um I'll get on to
what I was uh what I was going to ask
initially so citizens advice conducted
some internal case analysis I found that
86 of customers moved to prepayment were
in contact with the supplier is the use
of prepayment medicine means to recover
debt really uses the last resort I'll
start with Miss Russia it is absolutely
for us yes
yeah absolutely yeah
um
what steps to take to support customers
that are impairment difficulty before we
move them to a prepayment and what so
and what sort of level of debt would we
consider
I am so we would try and contact the
customer we would look degree payment
plans our payment plans will go up to
five years and the average level of debt
for a customer that goes on to
prepayment meter is just over one
thousand pounds it sort of goes on to
prepayment meter um under uh an
installation under one is just over one
thousand pounds
already on yeah all of our customers are
already on uh prepaid but obviously you
know the key thing to remember this is a
demographic issue and they are it's
mostly in rented accommodation and
there's a lot of change of tenancy
happening all the time so 25 of my
customers move every year so
um circumstances in any particular
household can change do change very
regularly
um but yeah we switch people to credit
mode
um every week
is there a minimum level of debt where
you would I think our process kicks in
after about three months so but I think
generally because our customers are
relatively newer we don't have quite the
same levels of debt as British gas we
try to capture the process and capture
the issue a lot earlier on
um and as Richard said you know
switching people to prepay often
actually saves the money as well so it
helps them to cut their debt going
forward
yeah
Mr share the times investigation that
we've talked about at length
revealed wouldn't pursued for customers
with vulnerabilities such as mental
health disorders physical disabilities
children with asthma that same internal
case analysis advice found 85 percent of
people using a prepayment meter would
meet off Jim's definition of
vulnerability
what steps do you take to identify
and and assess whether it's safe and
practical to move
to prepayment
so obviously we have to have contact
with a customer so
um in our definition of vulnerability
would be somebody has children under
five years old somebody is there
somebody over the age of 85
cognitive impairments such as dementia
but but often that can be established
through
contact with the customer I understand
but if we have no contact with the
customer it's it's it's impossible to
establish that now I think there might
be an opportunity for us to have
something that is across industry but
actually goes beyond just the energy
industry to understand have a common
definition amongst service providers as
to what vulnerability is and to have a
central register that would make it far
easier that means that we would know as
long as the voters are always kept up to
date we would we would know but if we
can't contact a customer then that's why
we then have arvato involved they go to
the door if the customer doesn't answer
the door there's only so much that we
can do
I'm right in thinking that there is some
link to DWP for warm homes this is a
scheme that's right so there's
potentially something that could be done
around I think that I absolutely think
that there is a lot that could be done
around this it just requires but I think
it has to go beyond the energy industry
I think you should uh go at other
essential service providers as well
because what that would do is it would
mean that we would have something I mean
nothing's ever foolproof it would have
something that was more satisfactory
than relying on actually having contact
with the customer
that same investigation found British
gas agents continued to remotely switch
customers as we just discussed from uh
from credit to to prepayment despite
Centric of publicly stating that it
would be stopped
is that still ongoing no no and then
look I was there was a question earlier
on to the um the person from arvato
um about my comments she was absolutely
my comments were about the behavior that
I observed in some of the videos the
language used about being excited about
um forced entry into home and the second
one was the the remote mode switch
rather than tried to go to the home we
had a warrant so we we had the right to
do that we made a very public statement
because of our concerns around some of
the issues with regard to prepayment
because we've been a very public
statement just the week before that
now you'll ask if I made a statement
then and somebody that how can I tell
you now it's not been done all I can
tell you is to reinforce the fact that
that should not be done
okay
um and finally from me how many
customers contacted you to complain that
they'd been moved when it was not safe
for them and what happens with that
information what do you do with that
information since the Times report we've
had around 300 customers that have
written to us to say that they feel
they've been moved incorrectly we're
looking into every one of those cases if
that's the case they will reverse it
will make it right
okay thank you thank you we're horribly
behind time but uh Ian levery I um
the six week pause in the pre-payment
media fittings in River switching comes
to one end I think and probably
day's time at the end of March what's
your intention at the end of that period
are you going to revert the type who
change the policy
so so firstly
what we've got to do is to understand
before we in British gas would think
about restarting this practice we've got
to understand whether there's a systemic
issue in our processes so we would not
restart that until investigations and
our investigation won't be done until I
think the end of April so we would not
restart and often also have their
investigation and we're under a
moratorium from off gem as well so that
won't restart for us the end of March
but but what I really want is for us to
figure out that this goes beyond the
energy industry
what do we do to help people that cannot
pay their bills this is not something
that can be solved by centrica or by any
Energy company
the question is how do we want to treat
people that can't afford to pay for
their heating to can't afford to pay for
their food can't afford to pay for the
rent can't afford to pay the mortgage
and I think that requires something
industry Regulators government citizens
advice Bureau other um consumer groups
to come to an agreement how do we fix
that now unfortunately that's going to
take time but for us in central we won't
we start unless we're sure there are no
systemic issues in our process
you mentioned
um the the issues yeah about vulnerable
people one engagement are you hard with
a government about a basically a social
type tariff a social discount sort of
tariff for those people who you
mentioned who I find it very difficult
to to survive we've had ongoing
conversations and I spoke to the energy
Minister just after this story
um broken media to discuss what we were
doing what's the immediate point and
then what could the solution be in the
longer term and and I think I wasn't a
fan of social tariffs at first when I
when I took this job but the more I look
into the more I understand about some of
our consumer the more I think this could
make perfect sense now it could be in a
number of different uh guises one is a
social tariff could be something whereby
um your is means tested effectively and
the um either a settlement mechanism
between energy companies so those that
can afford it pay more and those that
can't pay less and there's a settlement
mechanism or something that's
administered by the DWP some of the
conversations I also had around the
universal support that were given for
consumers and which was brought last
year was the support from government was
very
um very positively received I lobbied
quite hard to have that and be more
targeted support because it gets support
the people that don't need it and if we
would take that support away we could
give more to those that desperately
needed so so those are the two main
areas of conversation I've had but I
would be supportive of something that
comes in I think it should be funded
from General taxation rather than from
energy consumers because that's more
Progressive but that will require
um uh quite some quite some discussion
the bullet I'm well equally you know
this is a subject we've looked at a lot
look fundamentally what we have here is
an affordability problem and people in
those lower couple of deciles of income
their incomes have not gone up anywhere
like the rate of inflation that applies
to them so fuel food which is the things
that have been driving inflation the
disproportionate amount of their
expenditure so you know clearly what we
need is to address that income issue I
think the best way to go about that is
through some kind of social discount on
energy bills because
it's obviously better for that customer
that money goes you know directly to
where it's needed in other words keeping
their house warm or keeping the lights
on I think you know the experience that
we've had through the ebb scheme going
through this winter has been you know
phenomenally enlightening as to the
impact that that can have but you know
clearly we need
um some kind of social discount to help
customers through this affordability
problem and I you know I don't think
this is something that's going to go
away I think there's a long-term
requirement and it is bigger than the
current warm home discount
but it does come down to better
targeting so that the cost of it can be
managed and
um yeah there needs to be a long run
solution to this problem because it's
not about to go away
you know when vulnerable people just
simply cannot afford to pay
their gas and electricity bills who
should pay
okay I think it goes beyond just gas and
electricity
um I mean that's what this is no I
understand but I think I think what's
really important is that what we find
with our customers our customers are
amazing people and they try to pay
and if they can't pay the gas and
electricity bill they're also not able
to pay for their food they're not be
able to pay for the rent they can't pay
the council tax now
we could see that energy companies could
could absorb it I believe that Centric
of British gas is the only energy
retailer in the UK that's making a
profit
most other companies are making a loss
half the market has gone vast in the
past year in the past 18 months so there
is a market where there is very little
profit in energy retail to subsidize
those they can pay I would also say that
the vulnerability definitions that we
got just they don't dig into account
Financial vulnerability that is a huge
gap
it talks about mental health it doesn't
talk about financial vulnerability I
think that the way that we should be for
this are Progressive Way is to pay for
it through General taxation
[Music]
suggested that the profit margins and
and losses by certain companies I think
we're both sitting here in our role as
the head of a licensed energy supplier
licensed energy suppliers are not making
profits I know some energy companies are
making progress but not in the business
of supplying customers I think a figure
was Creative Energy UK a few weeks ago
or something like minus two percent is
the profit margin otherwise everybody's
making a loss so somehow if if
vulnerable customers can't afford to pay
that cost clearly does have to be
socialized because licensed energy
companies do not have that money and it
would have to come from either from
other energy consumers or from taxpayers
you know
pretty much the same group of people one
way or another it has to come from
somewhere else because energy companies
licensed energy suppliers don't have
this money and it's not allowed for in
any of the price gaps if I'm if only at
the moment technically what happens is
it's been socialized across Society so
it's regressive because there's an
element of the price Camp which deals
with Bandits and so those who don't pay
not prepay no but but those who don't
pay
um that's socialized and it's
essentially it's added to the bill of
everybody else and so it might sound a
bit Rich for me as the chief executive
and Energy company to say it should be
the general taxpayer but at the moment
those that are struggling be able to pay
their bill are paying for those that are
either unable or unwilling to pay their
bill and and I just think that like the
cost of failures of other energy
companies that's just not right and
because it's highly highly regressive
okay okay I'm sorry that we've timed out
I think we could go on but we really
must get off gym uh in before we have to
finish today so thank you to both of you
just last demonstration you've
referenced a lot the internal
investigation and you've been unable to
tell us whether wrongdoing has happened
or not subject to that investigation
will you share a copy of that with us
when it's ready yes thank you thank you
to both of you and we're not gonna do a
very quick turnaround of possibilities
uh to our next Witnesses uh where we'll
be welcoming Jonathan brilly the chief
executive of the energy regulator off
gem uh Neil Lawrence who is the director
of retail at off Gem and Catherine Scott
who's the director of enforcement and
emerging issues uh at off gem so we'll
just get you comfortably uh sat and
actually some new cups and water for you
thank you
um I'm always conscious that we have you
on last and that means that you get less
time uh with us and I don't want you to
feel left out so we're going to try and
make a quick bit of progress uh Mr
brilli just to come to you straight away
the thing that I'm troubled with after
the evidence today is on the one hand we
have this times expose a which so shows
completely egregious examples of
forcible entry into vulnerable people's
homes to forcibly install prepayment
visas which will end up turning off
their electricity and gas because they
can't afford to pay their bills we have
the Bayless avato saying they were just
doing what British gas or their energy
suppliers told them to do and then we
had British gas and the energy supplier
telling us that they don't know whether
something's gone wrong or not they're
doing an investigation and they were
sorry to see it happen it looks to me
like everyone's either blaming each
other or just trying not to be kind of
upfront about this what seems to me a
very clear breach of the license
conditions what's your initial view on
that so look we are deeply concerned
about not only the reports in the times
the reports that have been appearing for
some time around the behavior of energy
companies with regards to the forced
insulation of prepayment meters now to
step back from this we are working
through one of the biggest gas crises
we've had in living memory and so
families are under Financial pressure
that has not been experienced when
within the energy system in my memory we
are seeing people even with government
support that is paying almost a third of
our bills seeing a bills Rising by 250
roughly compared to where they were a
year and a half ago now we have been
clear throughout the last year the
sector's focus needs to be on its most
vulnerable customers the reason we
launch market compliance reviews I'm
sure we'll come to how we thought about
British gas in the moment but the reason
we launched those micro compliance
reviews because our message was really
simple if we are going to have a
successful and profitable energy
industry then they need to look after
their vulnerable customers
now we think our rules are clear there
is a lot of judgment when you think
about whether or not it is safe and
practical to put a prepaid meter in
someone's home but we think that the
principles are clear
we look we wrote to the suppliers in
November to make sure they were clear on
our rules and we launched a further
compliance review in January that's
going to look precisely at the systems
and processes and outcomes for customers
who have had these prepayment meters
installed now alongside that we are
checking to see if we need to tighten
those rules and we are working with the
industry and consumer groups on a new
code of practice and we expect that to
be in place with broad support by the
end of March but I need to be clear with
this committee our priority is in making
sure this industry gets its act in order
therefore they will not be restarting
forced installation and prepayment
meters at the end of March and only when
and if they can establish their acting
in accordance with that new code of
practice so we are deeply concerned
about this we have investigations and
compliance reviews ongoing but you know
a message to Chris and to all of the
industry is you need to fix things now
you don't need to wait for our reviews
to conclude that's very welcome but in
uh admittedly before you were running
off gem uh often took action about this
issue I've got the copy of the notice
from 2018 and in it it says off gem will
take tough action if the suppliers fail
to treat their vulnerable customers in
the right way is this not symptomatic of
the comments from energy UK last time
that the energy suppliers look at off
Gem and just think you're not really
going to enforce the rules so we can do
what we like well look
um you know the following the reviews we
had of oxira we have completely changed
the way we do compliance so in the past
in 2018 2019 we've relied on complaints
we've resolved complaints and we did it
pretty reactively the compliance reviews
we launched this year were proactively
looking across the sector and Its
Behavior and we're responding to those
and they have made big changes which I'm
happy to come to now now equally you
know those aren't going to be all the
answer we always rely on others
including complaints and including
whistleblowers to make to make us aware
of what's happening and that's what
happened in the case of British gas the
reason why we suspended active after the
times investigation was in part some of
the cases you've raised but also the
behavior of the operatives involved we
don't just have license conditions on
the forced installation of prepayment
meters we are very clear vulnerable
customers need to be treated fairly and
that means vulnerable customers need to
be treated with respect
thank you uh just coming to the market
compliance review because it I mean it
it is slightly uh it's more than
slightly concerning quite frankly that
you did a review of the energy suppliers
and how they dealt with their vulnerable
customers and British gas came out as
the Exemplar in the industry and if the
time stories are all correct how can
that possibly be the best of all the
energy suppliers how did that market
compliance review go so wrong well look
um
when we did the vulnerability
compository there were two vulnerability
to pay a one on vulnerability we did
identify weaknesses British gas we did
identify weaknesses particularly around
their relationship with their third
parties throughout that process we heard
complaints around the forced
installation of prepayment meters and
that's why we're looking more closely at
it now but clearly the picture we have
from British gas and the behavior of
avato simply don't match so that's why
we've launched the investigation and
that's where we'll learn Earth what's
happened but to be clear chair those
compliance reviews identified a huge
number of issues the industry needs to
deal with I was saying publicly in
November that the industry needs to up
its game on the way it treats vulnerable
customers and indeed the way we have
customer service in general so for
example 900 000 direct debits have had
to be reassessed to make sure they're
set at the right level we have made sure
across the piece that companies are
better at identifying vulnerable
customers making sure that fits these
processes but also they are put on the
Priority Services register we have also
made sure that supplies give additional
credit so when prepayment meters are at
the point they can they self-disconnect
they should be offered extra credit by
their suppliers and I know Bill
complains about the result but utilita
weren't doing that they accepted that
and that's why they paid around 850 000
pounds in address
now we I can continue with the examples
that we have but I need to let the
suppliers understand one thing you know
if we go back to store Marvin last year
and the behavior of the networks it
costs them 10 million pounds because
they were not proactive enough and they
were not protecting their vulnerable
customers if we find through this
compliance review or indeed if we find
in general suppliers don't up their game
then those fines will be levied here now
Chris is right the sector is in recovery
from a massive gas crisis over the last
two years but it would be a shame if a
sector that does need to return to a
reasonable profitability is stop doing
so by off-chem's enforcement action
because we are forced to demonstrate to
companies that will cost them all if
they don't follow the rules thank you
and in the latest Market compliance
review I can see you you're examining a
number of issues including internal
processes and controls the flow of
management information
um were you concerned by the answers
that we heard earlier how and this was
just British gases example but they were
the witness the the audit and risk
committee the board didn't seem to be
getting the information about the
alleged breaches of the license
conditions surely there's a problem
about the corporate governance of these
suppliers isn't there well Leo may want
to kick in yeah so just just to
reiterate we do ask them supplies for
their Assurance records when we do
Market compliance reviews and we will
ask for any Assurance records we this as
well as doing the substantive testing we
think it's really important that we
understand how companies are set up at
the top path but also the experiences of
customers are receiving on the ground
because clearly there's been a mismatch
here from the previous review as
Jonathan aligned to you'll look at the
papers that have gone to the audit and
risk committee and you'll be able to see
yourselves whether this issue has been
raised or not absolutely yeah okay and
just the very last thing for me can we
please change the language it's not
self-disconnection it's not someone
actively choosing to turn off their
electricity or gas is that they're not
able to pay the bill and the supplier
turns it off if we can change just one
simple thing in the changes ahead I
think we need to change the language
around self-disconnection I think it's
absolutely right thank you bimafalami
please thank you chair
um
Mr brilli you'd anybody warn you or
rather anybody who works for you in
Austin
that maybe with British gas there was a
problem
so before sorry before any public
um press reports or anything came out so
we had extensive conversation with
consumer groups who were warning us
about Behavior across the industry
actually not necessarily targeted on
British gas and in fact you know before
I came in front of this committee last
time we spent time with both the
companies and with the consumer groups
to identify what the issue was and that
led to the compliance review because
that's how we understand and get the
evidence around Behavior but also led to
us to look again at the code of practice
to make sure companies are clear on the
rules now I'm not pretending that these
are simple judgments trying to
understand the vulnerability of a family
who may not want to talk to you is
complex but it's a supplier's
responsibility to deliver against that
so one of the and I appreciate its pot
calling kettle black when we say we talk
about a lot of reviews you know
politicians like reviews as much as of
Chen
um
you have
often said look you've seen evidence
you've heard things and then you do a
review and that gets the half the
problem and not just in this area you
could name lots of other areas I'm sure
do you think as a process that's really
adequate I mean to what extent my
question view is to what extent are you
monitoring real-time information and
data so you don't need a review you can
stamp things out where they go wrong so
look we do have data monitoring again
Neil can expand on that but what we're
looking here to establish the evidence
of what's happened is to look at the way
in which companies are behaved the way
in which they've treated customers and
indeed the way in which their operators
are treated customers now you can't do
that without an extensive process that
looks at the behaviors involved last
week we launched a partnership with
citizens advice to make sure that we're
not just getting the company's paperwork
around this and it comes back to the
questions in the previous session we are
going to hear directly from customers
and customer experiences that does take
time right just and just to add to what
Jonathan said yeah absolutely we are
improving our monitoring functions what
currently are the monitoring functions
so we receive a range of reports on a
monthly and quarterly basis from
suppliers across the market that's
domestic and B2B and we use that to make
our risk assessment of where things
going on we match that with reports that
we get from the consumer and charity
groups who meet with them on a monthly
basis and they report issues to us we
get some whistleblowing and in addition
to that we do do some monitoring of
social media to really get an
understanding of what's going on in the
market we recognize that that's a
journey we've changed our operating
model in off gem to move to a
professions-based model to invest in
those resources and the different
capabilities such as digital to make
those processes easier so we can get to
the heart of the model and the
compliance will change of approach the
compliance enforcement strategy of going
to Market compliance reviews is
proactive so we're looking at those and
say look across the market now we're
identifying things that we want more
information on and we're challenging the
suppliers to what they gain and if you
can continue to do that process we may
need to go in more in depth appreciating
it may need more sample testing more
substantive testing it may be more
invasive but we get to the end of that
process we hope to improve the standards
right the way across the because I mean
industry if that process works well you
won't actually need to be asking the
suppliers constantly for these reports
you should just know things and that
should make everybody's life a lot
easier just I suppose one last question
to what
I was very struck Mr breely where your
comment about effectively most people in
this industry aren't making money in the
realtail market
and obviously there's been a price shock
and we're not you know unique to that in
the United Kingdom it's happening all
over Europe
how do you see
us getting to an equilibrium
where we have businesses that make a
reasonable profit
at the same time as fewer people being
forced into the terrible situations that
we've heard about today over the last
couple of hours how now I don't I'm not
asking about the process of getting
there but actually what does that world
look like
hello I've I've said to our board there
are three things we need to do with the
retail sector so first of all as you say
is return it to reasonable profitability
we cannot create companies without
sufficient investment behind them second
is to move them to a more financially
resilient Place certainly than they were
a year ago and we have made a great deal
of progress doing that but neither of
those two things could or should happen
without service standards improving and
I go a bit further than simply talking
about vulnerable customers we think
service standards need to increase
across the board let me give you one
example of our compliance reviews last
year so Eon fifty percent of calls are
dropped before they're answered now if
you're a vulnerable customer how do you
tell your company You're vulnerable if
you can't get through on the phone
so my view is those three things go
together the ideal with the industry is
we will continue to amend the price Gap
and we have made significant changes to
the way it works we will be monitoring
and maintaining Financial resilience but
the industry as a whole needs to improve
its standards and last question Jeff I
may
which regulatory changes if any are
required to get to that world that you
have just outlined so I think the
compliance reviews we have the way in
which we proactively check across the
sector should drive up standards I am
interested come back to your previous
question about whether there are some
automatic ways you can build in
financial incentives for for good
service standards but it's my belief
that by doing that and by continuing to
run these reviews they're not one-off
they should be overtime and as you say
accompanied with real data we will be
able to move the sector to an equity
that I think works for everyone but to
do that we do need the suppliers to take
this seriously the other thing I would
say though and you've heard me say this
publicly before behind this problem is a
huge problem of affordability right now
now the government have put huge amounts
of Support over the last six months you
know we were talking in in August of
prices that might be five or six
thousand pounds right now but the simple
fact is if you are low income if you are
a high energy user if you have a child
with disability who relies on
electricity for for their equipment or
you live in a drafty social housing home
your energy bill is extremely difficult
to afford now if we don't tackle that
together then it's very hard to create
the rules in the system around it that's
going to get to that place that you're
describing and that's why we are Keen to
work with government on a social tariff
or something else that will address that
problem okay thank you thank you just
very quickly at Neil Lawrence can I just
check I understood your answer uh to
bimafalami correctly about the
compliance reviews I think what you were
acknowledging was that you're moving
from a process where you were looking
originally at processes I.E what is the
flow of decision making in the business
what are your policy documents and kind
of ticking the boxes to looking more at
outcomes with customer engagement so
that was an acknowledgment I think that
previously in your Market compliance
reviews you weren't that focused on
outcomes Sunrise so we were focused on
outcomes and some of the compliers as I
said to the direct debit review clearly
made some some substantial improvements
for for outcomes but we recognize the
process is new we're evolving the
process we're doing more work in this
compliance review on prepayment to look
at those consumer outcomes absolutely we
support the use of the consumer line
with with systems advice we may use that
again on future reviews into anything
else to collect that information and
data as we evolve the process to give us
better confidence in what the suppliers
are ultimately doing to protect
consumers can I just say one thing
chance before before we move on one
thing I need to be open and honest with
this committee about is is with all of
this compliance work
even if it is perfect and we accept it's
an evolving sort of process we are not
going to capture everything that happens
within companies so there will always be
behaviors and incidences that are
outside of our ability to look at those
that's why we need to maintain a
reactive as well as a proactive function
thank you I've got a quick supplementary
very briefly chair thank you you said 50
of the calls have dropped so that's
people who are trying to contact and
unfortunately give up in the end
could you tell me whether those calls
are premium rare or free
I'll need to confirm that my my
understanding is that um that they may
well be free but we'll write back to you
and confirm that because I can't answer
for certain I think I'm right in saying
that those calls are zero zero eight
zero eight numbers so they are free but
that's only for my landline is my
information could you I will come back
to you and give you that grateful thank
you Jeff thank you Alan Brown yeah
thanks here
um
do you agree with certain advice they're
moving customers to prepayment meters is
just the way suppliers to disconnect
them without breaking the rules
so I don't accept that as necessarily
what's happening I've spoken to a lot of
customers on prepayment meters in fact
I've spoken to a lot of customers who
are struggling to pay their bills who
prefer it as a payment method just to
clarify things if you look at a dual
full build right now today it is
slightly more expensive it is well it's
more expensive than it is for direct
debit for example and I expect the
committee have seen the reports in the
Press about what may happen tomorrow
but customers still prefer it because it
gives them Direct Control so not
everybody but some customers choose it
because they say a question what do you
talk to you so you speak to customers so
I I've spoken to double figure customers
who have said to me they prefer this
system I'm not saying that's right for
everybody but I think there is an
important Point here that for some
customers particularly if this is smart
replay which is something we should talk
about here they prefer to have this
system because it allows them to say I'm
going to take this much more energy this
week or this month for some people that
is really really important it's very
hard to do that with the credit Richard
still off gym make or have companies
make that once people are forced to
enter prepayment meter
that they're not that
you know they're not actually then
effectively cut off they're soluble
access heating enabled
um to heat their homes so we have rules
that say suppliers need to be proactive
about people who do get up get cut off
when their credit Runs Out
and so they need to respond now the
rules around that are they to offer
additional credit to customers when that
situation occurs now that is limited
that can't be unending but cut supplies
should be proactively contacting their
customers absolutely let's proactive
approach which should companies be doing
when somebody's in a prepayment meter
and they'll fight that because it's 10
pounds and then if they don't put money
back in
you have someone on smart meter they you
can see that they have been disconnected
because they haven't been put the credit
on that allows them to use the energy
they need you should be contacting them
you should be proactively in my mind
trying to link them with Charities and
debt advice to make sure they can begin
to find ways to manage their bills I've
seen suppliers good suppliers actually
sit down with that customer look at
their energy use and say well what can
we do differently to reduce the bill and
you should be offering them additional
support credits so some extra credit to
help them manage until for example your
benefits get repaid or your monthly pay
comes in so those are things we should
we should be doing and you're monitoring
the company to you making sure that all
these checks have been undertaken well
that's been I mean the only one's coming
on this but it's part of the compliance
processes we have yeah and we did get
that data on on us on customers who
disconnect themselves we are monitoring
some of that information later this year
we may look at those issues in more
depth in line with our our plans our own
Market compliance reviews but we have
soon we're prepared for people and
prepayment meters is the big topic of
the day and obviously more and more
people are getting four so many
prepayment mirrors in New England May
review this further just to expand on
where we've got to on the code of
practice so we started that discussion
first of all thinking it was a
conversation about who this should apply
to actually there are three areas where
we are going to reset expectations and
as I say industry won't start until
we're confident they're being met first
is absolutely around how you interpret
safe and practicable so which households
could this or should this apply to
Second category is how which will Define
much more clearly the sorts of teams you
have in place when they go to install
prepayment meters but the third category
which I think you're alluding to is what
happens afterwards what is the Aftercare
now if you imagine you have a vulnerable
family in extremely difficult
circumstances who have a prepayment
meter for the first time we want to make
sure there is an entire care package
around that family that focuses on their
needs and just to say critical to that
and something that we are pushing as far
as we can with the existing law is the
use of a smart prepayment meter so it is
much more effective and much more
efficient and much easier for a company
to offer support when smart prepay is
installed compared to traditional meters
into your question
um what we want the suppliers to do is
do those checks because they're in the
license conditions anyway it shouldn't
take off gym to come along to change the
behavior so well you know well we will
do these checks we will do these
compliance reviews ultimately the
suppliers are responsible for those
license conditions and we're asking them
to act now
obviously been any concerns about
whether that's happening or not because
you've said you've read it you've read
the challenge of suppliers to up their
game before so is that an area that
you've been challenged on top of their
game to make sure with increasing
prepayment meters that people are
actually able to access energy and
they're not just getting cut off we'll
we continue to engage with suppliers on
the way they look after vulnerable
customers as a whole including that but
look the things you should be doing as a
supplier to identify vulnerabilities to
make sure people don't get to that point
where you have that crisis point where a
prepayment feature is being installed
there are a whole set of things they
should be doing so you need to identify
customers vulnerabilities you to
identify when they're struggling to pay
you need to try to get them all the
repayment plan you need to try to make
sure they have access to help and advice
and you need to try and help them manage
their energy use we expect suppliers to
a whole set of things around that and
those are the sorts of things we monitor
but coming back to Neil's point you know
it should not take the regulator to
check every single detail of every
single supplier all the time and
suppliers should be doing this
automatically if they're not we are
going to have to send a very strong
signal and there is only one way to do
that and that is the issue fines
we did that I think Jonathan alluded to
it already
um last year we made a couple of orders
against uh companies who weren't
complying with those rules who weren't
offering additional support credit I've
always
well uh in in that case
um they changed their policies and
processes and they paid compensation to
customers and a payment to our address
fund of about 850 000
just quickly after anything you alluded
to standard charges so
who's who's pushed for a change and
unfair higher standing charges are
applied to prepayment matters we are
examining all of the costs around
prepaymenters we are looking at ways to
I've asked you about it before this is
obviously I'm driven this I've come from
government or is it so we are driving
this now clearly there have been reports
um about what government may do in the
interim the problem we have is you know
the way in which we will find to
equalize the cost of prepayment Misses
versus direct debit for example we'll be
around looking at the underlying cost
structure and the problem with that and
I know this is a it's a frustrating
answer for me this you have to go
through the industry governance
processes that we have but we hope that
there will be a way of bridging that
into living something quite quickly
and what engagement since the last gave
evidence what engagement you had with
government and the potential social
tariff so we have a lot of Engagement
government on pricing regulation in
general including a social tariff but I
see it before you the same as last time
saying this is fundamental to getting at
the heart of the under buying problem
which is the affordability right now for
many families
are a good way to go so my view is you I
think I've gone as far as I can as a
regulator I think we should explore it I
think it is a good option we need that
or something else but really it's up to
the politicians thank you if that's okay
then sorry thank you lastly so Bob Neal
Please Mr Berry just a couple of things
please
the existing law in relation to the
granting of warrants very heavily
depends upon the court with virtually no
discretion accepting the accuracy of
that which is said by the energy
supplier or their agents is that a
satisfactory State of Affairs so
um I think I think as you're aware that
you know it is difficult for a regulator
to comment on the courts in general but
let me put it let me put it this way
um
from afar and without offering advice or
influence to the courts it seems to me
the role of the courts is not clear
and I think it would help all of us if
that were clarified in law now
the new Department the energy department
plus the ministry of Justice have to
prioritize what they do and there's a
whole set of things that people like us
are bidding for in the energy act the
new energy the Infinity build that's in
the house already but in my mind it
would be helpful if that were clarifying
the 1954 Act is very old and I'm very
unqualified so you know it's very clear
and the final thing is in terms of that
ensuring the quality the accuracy of the
information that's given to the courts
that managers think you're right let's
look again at the 54 Act and the tests
uh would you regard it as something
where as regulator you would want to
take action against a supplier who did
not ensure
um or didn't have adequate systems in
place to ensure that they are their
agents provided accurate and reliable
information to the courts under the
existing law so look I mean I think we
we have our set of rules and regulations
around this we have compliance processes
around this
I we would need to consider with the
courts what the appropriate role prompt
is that the only thing I highlight is
getting in between someone you know in
effect a witness in court and a judge is
a complex issue but it's really an issue
isn't it it is absolutely and I think
you know I'd start from the basics what
other courts expected to establish and
then on that basis what's the best way
of establishing it thank you very much
thank you and just very lastly in
response to the time story I think off
gem instructed suppliers to start to
review the forced installation of
prepayment meters in households uh and
see whether they needed to be reversed
and compensated are you actively
monitoring those uh reviews and have
people already started to have them
removed and been compensated so supplies
are certainly report back to us they are
actively looking at this we don't have
figures for you yet but as we issue the
new code of practice we will ask
companies to look back at the prepaid
meters they'd installed and then report
back to us and often people watching the
committee when we've shown a light on
unacceptable corporate behavior in this
country we'll say to us well what
happens as a consequence can you just be
really clear with the committee that if
you find breaches of licensed conditions
what is it that you're going to do about
it let's just lay out the principle the
principle is you fix the problem you
compensate someone who is affected and
we have discretion around in a sense
that the incentive effect across the
industry so in this case I would imagine
you know without prejudice etc etc I'd
imagine that means offering restitution
so having to change the meter that was
installed some people may want to keep
it some people may want to change it
offering compensation and if it's
systemic and widespread then we will be
finding the companies involved thank you
so that brings us to the end of the
session I'm not sure whether it's good
news or not but I think this is probably
the last time that we will interact on
energy policy
um certainly with me in the chair due to
changes that will be coming to the
committee in the next few weeks so thank
you to all of you for your contribution
and your work with the committee over
the last few years we'll now bring the
session to an end order order